I'm ready to Jamie Choo,
Choo Choo Choo Choo Choo Choo Choo Choo Choo Choo
retail experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Uh,
we're full law
[inaudible] fear and is three dimension.
No t share
this.
It says do mushrooms on it and you can get this at our,
the great.com.
[inaudible] that's,
that's my tour this year.
It's the do mushroom store.
Say Good tour.
It's a good name.
It's a good message.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a good thing you're doing like doing the Lord's work,
trying to get the word out,
but the Lord's product.
You're doing the Lord's work.
Does anyone has ever been doing the Lord's work?
It's the man who invented trim fast.
How many people,
by the way,
worldwide participate in shrimp fest?
Every year?
I heard it was over a billion.
Is that true?
Mr Shapiro?
I,
that was the last stats I saw or over a billion.
Over a billion.
What's really,
we're doing fairly well in that regard.
It's like how many billions are,
they're definitely,
that's not most of them,
but we're getting there.
This 7 billion people and out of the 7 billion people on earth,
1 billion every year participation through assessed,
you know this year it's August 29th 30th and 31st he's a really,
yeah.
You so you give it three days.
Yeah.
What's ideally for the average shroom or how many,
how many trips did they do in those three days?
Oh,
one just one day.
When it's time to do it?
Yeah.
Oh,
just one.
Only one.
Yeah.
You don't like to do like multiple on a weekend.
I have done that this last year.
Invest.
We just kept taking them three days just in cabin.
Just fucking going.
Yeah.
We're worrying about like being that dude from pink Floyd that never comes back.
No.
I would stop worrying about that.
You stopped worrying.
There's only like barely any guys I've ever seen like that.
Barely any,
yeah.
I don't know if it's from that or just mild schizophrenia.
There's always that,
right?
Yeah.
The the real problem is like what if you have mental illness plus psychedelics?
If you,
if you're just a totally normal person,
you have normal balance levels of whatever hormones your head.
But then that's the only thing if you're prone to prone to that schizophrenia,
that's the only time I'd be like them don't,
if you haven't,
your family maybe don't.
Yeah,
I would say if reality is at all slippery,
Huh?
Just hold off on that.
You're barely hold bonds.
I can't really get yourself a good foundation.
But then there's the other problems.
If you take a lot of the drugs that people take,
like even antidepressants,
you're not supposed to ever take mushrooms when you taking notes.
Not True.
There's different kinds of enterprise.
Ask Your doctor.
I asked Mike,
how's your doctor?
I asked mine,
Ari Shaffir here for you.
Tell them what you're doing and then they'll help you with like medically
through that.
Okay.
So I asked him about,
hey,
I heard this thing about,
well,
Moa,
I inhibitors [inaudible] an Ssri inhibitors.
So Mike,
uh,
her mushrooms counteract badly with those and he goes,
and I don't know which one's which,
but he goes,
no,
that's that one.
You're taking this type of uh,
anti depression medication.
Oh.
So it wouldn't interfere at all.
Okay.
So you really should ask your doctor and find out whether or not it's an issue.
Yeah.
So with you lose zero issue at all?
He goes,
no,
no.
That's fair.
It's like that.
But the minute somebody didn't tell him not to protect antibiotics and you had
to say,
we have to say why and they go,
because if it's that the antibiotics won't work anymore,
then I won't drink.
But if it's just as going to make drinking awesome,
then I'm going to drink.
Well,
I've heard people that have talking about,
um,
taking meor I eh Meo wise mano aiming oxidase inhibitors and taking those,
uh,
with anything like anything dimethyltryptamine based,
whether it's a real ask or DMT or anything along those lines.
And it becomes like really potent to the point where it dangerously potent.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I think Chemical Maoi m I'm saying it fucked up.
M a o i's motto aiming oxidase inhibitors,
like the pharmaceutical versions of it are extremely strong.
The really strong and you're not supposed to take anything DMT based with them
because that's the whole,
the whole basis of Iowasca is I'm a natural Maoi inhibitor,
which is called harming mixed in with the leaves that have the DMT.
That's why you,
you can take it in through drinking it.
They said some of those things that flood your brains with like,
it's almost like the inhibitors shut off so it floods your brains,
you get super happy like ecstasy or some things like that and then that all
drops out and then you're like,
oh I need your body sort of stopped producing depletion and shit like that.
Yeah,
there will you expand.
I mean Tim Ferriss has this statement or this saying it was a really good saying
is that there are no biological free lunches,
you know,
and that everything has a price.
You drink coffee,
then you crash,
you know,
take speed.
Then you come down,
you know,
you drink alcohol,
you feel great,
then you're hung over in order to achieve these hyper natural states.
There's some sort of consequence is vacuum vacuums can't exist,
right?
Yeah.
There's like there's a pull and a push and there's like,
there's something going on.
Every time you do something that fucks with your consciousness.
It's just the idea is finding like what does the least amount of damage and the
most amount of benefit.
Yeah.
Fun.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like I'm gonna get fucked up.
What's it going to be on?
Yeah.
I like go math,
which I pull it back.
Well,
he's a lot of people that are like,
I am not going through this fucking thing.
So over.
Oh No.
Why would you not doing it?
Not Live with her at all times doing it.
Thank you.
You have met my mother and father in law.
No thank you.
I will be fucked up for this.
This is not a ride that you should take.
Seriously.
This is a ride.
You should be sober only when necessary.
Only when life are you doing surgery?
Yeah,
you should be sober.
Um,
are you going to Disneyland?
Why are you sober?
Why Sony?
You doing what's wrong with you?
Somehow or another make a terrible decision when you're on the teapot.
I went,
yeah,
I'll be spending the teacups.
Those things where you spin around and they don't serve alcohol at Disneyland.
Huh?
Well they have alcohol at um,
California adventure and they had the,
the outside place with all the bars.
Yeah.
Which is like downtown Disney.
You have alcohol.
There were restaurants.
It's not like Mormon alcohol or it's like a 2% of sip peer.
Technically alcohol.
It's real alcohol.
They have real alcohol,
but I'm inside Disneyland is apparently only one place where you can get alcohol
and it's this place.
It's above pirates of the Caribbean and you have to pay like some insane amount
of like yearly money.
Thrilled to go there.
Yeah.
You have to spend a shit load of money.
It costs like 25 granted joinders lessons.
We have a member.
Yeah.
What does that more than than that?
What does that shit called?
Club 33 or something like that.
Yeah,
something along those lines.
It's like CEOs of companies.
Yeah.
Dice have club 43 is his basement or something.
He wouldn't tell anybody why you called her that.
Maybe that's what it is.
They didn't.
I finally figured it out.
Hmm.
I don't remember.
You got to know what it is.
18 Ma.
Oh,
like a big fat fuck Jang Nash.
there.
You know what I'm talking about?
It's somebody you're Diaz impression is one of the best around and we,
I forgot about,
we used to have Diaz off.
I like the Brita Improv.
These fucking so cal Mexican comics stuff.
They have great the has and you're like,
let's do it.
Let's do it.
At the end of your headliner said,
do you remember that can beat me.
He beat me.
He yes was better.
He had,
his mannerisms were awesome.
Silent Bob got me.
He got me.
My voice might have been a little bit better.
A little bit more exact.
He also did the hand thing where it was like this weird like,
well he was also,
yeah,
he was just in the groove.
Nailed it.
He nailed it.
The cocaine,
the cocaine.
Next stop.
I need to just like doing that open shut up and shot.
Next up.
What?
Well,
he's also just having fun.
This guy that's,
that's the Joey Dee,
his mannerisms.
He had the mannerisms down.
I had a voice.
My voice was probably a little bit better than his,
but he overwhelmed me with his mannerisms.
He swore he took the title.
What am I going to say?
Yeah,
I forgot who want,
who would?
Yeah,
he'd beat me.
I gave it to him.
I said he won.
I gave it up.
I said,
that's better.
This is better.
Yeah.
You know stuff he says though,
that sounds like stuff.
He would say,
I guess I,
I did too.
Well,
so maybe it's just he couldn't beat him up.
He deserves to wait.
I forgot about that Joey.
He's the greatest guy that's ever walked the face of the planet and these three
d glasses kind of tripping out a little like little,
you have a lot behind each show,
so it's little.
Yeah,
the lava lamp is fucking weird.
The reason why wearing these shirts are,
should fear has these three d t w the why worn these shirts.
Why we're wearing these goggles.
He's a blast.
He's fucking ridiculous.
Paper glasses were wearing already has these new t shirts and if you wear these
glasses,
these tee shirts look three dimensional.
It's weird that no one's ever figured out a way to make three d work without
glasses.
Oh yeah,
they have.
But you go to the movies,
you always have glasses.
Yeah.
Just make the fucking screen in a three d movie for all time.
Three d movie screen.
Yeah.
But even those three d screens,
you have to wear glasses.
Yeah,
no bullshit.
Like the Nintendo,
we live in a horrible logo.
Our lives are worth anything.
OPO and Nintendo three Ds is an example of a small screen that you don't need
glasses and they do have small monitors that are good as it used it.
Getting there.
Is it better?
Is it better than the game boy graphics?
It's just came away with three d
like when you go to see like top level three d like Avatar.
We'll start with the best when we talked through that way,
that one place in the valley,
like that opening scene,
what's it doing is floating around with her all and let 3-d floating around
space.
I remember when the coming out of their pods and he's floating.
Yeah.
Uh,
well it was like the greatest 3d of all time.
Yeah.
You're like,
wow.
And the island,
the floating islands were like
the floating island.
I forgot about that.
You can't do that without glasses.
Right?
Not to that point yet.
To that point,
I mean it's still kind of small screens and not as good.
Last I checked,
I said I'm an interesting to somebody even figured out how to do that.
How to do it.
Yes.
Separate the red and the blue.
Fuck.
Yeah.
He figured out how to make people look like they're floating in front of you.
Give this extra dimensional aspect.
I remember the olden days when they had those spaceship movie,
three days,
like when I was young teens,
like 1412 something like that.
I would,
the ships would come over here and you'd be like,
what the fuck?
It's a lean back to avoid it.
I want that three d none of that bullshit.
They didn't give you now avatar was great.
Everything else is garbage.
Could you imagine if life was three d?
It is.
It's not three d like that.
Not like that.
That's really like that.
That's three D in this really weird freaky way where like you see a car accident
a mile away and all of a sudden it's in your face.
It was like a couple of good three d movies that would,
that slow motion movie was good and three D uh,
the new judge Dredd or something since city?
No,
it was like super slow motion.
They gave people,
the drug they gave were giving out with slow Mo,
so they give to Sloan with a dump them off this fucking giant roof and they die
and like an hour and a half.
Oh God.
Paul Slow Mo and then Jackass Three d,
that was the other,
those Avatar.
Those are the only three movies that have ever like fuck ya three to here where
I have a tar was insane.
They were flying when they were on those dragons flying around and it was in
three d like God,
it was like your mouth is open.
Just God.
It's incredible.
It's glorious.
It's got does other good in three d I never saw Godzilla movies do five at the
beginning and three at the end.
That's all they do and they give be garbage up front.
We cycled this when you're done with it,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
I'm breaking it right in front of them.
They know though.
I swear I do now.
I'm like cut John lows.
No,
this isn't acceptable anymore.
This movie's bad.
You can't tell us it's three days.
We're going in and saying it's going to be like four 50 and then fucking
nothing.
Five at the beginning,
three at the end.
That's all.
They give you five at the beginning,
five minutes of the beginning of three d and then at the end,
so you go on your way out.
Those though,
some garbage at you.
I remember it's three days,
no three the whole way you forget it because you won't even,
not even like atmosphere three d like depth,
nothing.
It's stupid.
They're just robbing ya
later.
And with the canyons and the big electrical nuclear power supply,
there was a few moments with the three d get the fucking falling of cranes.
Godzilla tele.
Yeah.
The only problem with Godzilla was,
spoiler alert,
spoiler,
if you never see God's
cow off on the right,
it's a fucking Godzilla.
Shut the power off on your stereo.
One.
You can kind of swirl looked in Congress,
somebody.
Here's the spoiler alert.
Kink con loses in every movie,
every movie,
every movie.
He never fucking wish do a fight club type King Kong.
We're going just fucking starts dominant and gets right off the statue of
whatever he's on the empire state building and just goes and fucking smashed
those underground to really think our puny bullets can penetrate the fucking
great Kong.
Did Gazelle ever fight King Kong?
While yeah,
but it doesn't make any sense.
Well,
they had to change the sizes the size yet until it was so much big.
King Kong was only 50 feet tall.
I've got till it was 500 feet tall.
That's fucking retarded.
Yeah.
But I'm King Kong has black people strength.
So that
was the bigger,
you get a a big black guy,
black person.
He's a gorilla and that's a lizard.
Fuck you.
Oh my God.
I just,
I just became a social justice warrior.
I give it for the right of freedom.
I'm on the wrong side.
I realize being friends with you should fear I'm on the wrong side.
Black people's drink pink column.
That's not a person.
How about fucking to justify that he fought even in that fight.
Well,
because it was a fucking Japanese production didn't make any sense.
The King Kong didn't even look like King Kong.
If you had that King Kong and the real King Kong in a lineup be booed.
Really be able to distinguish between the two of them.
They'd be like,
that is not the guy that fucked me.
I'm just the guy on the right.
The little short dude,
I don't know that 500 foot tall dude,
what fuck is he?
He's 10 times bigger than that other dude.
I know how to swim across the ocean.
That guys way bigger than the guy know Zillow [inaudible] here with radiation or
anything.
No explanation whatsoever.
Just they want you to be stupid because it's 1962 or whatever the fuck it was
when they made that movie.
There was no thinking about it.
What do you,
what do you,
I'm looking at a picture right now.
It's so hilarious of King Kong versus Godzilla because they cause King Kong
looks just like,
like just looks really,
it looks ridiculous.
They all,
I've watched him,
dude,
when I was a kid,
I fucking loved King Kong.
I love King Kong and my cousin Mike Glove Godzilla.
We even got into fisticuffs at one juncture away over was,
oh it was better Kong versus Godzilla.
Who would win?
Yeah,
that was before they had that movie or your [inaudible] were both six or
whatever the fuck we were five probably were five.
When we're arguing going knuckles up over who would win?
Got God versus taking children bottom over it.
We totally fought.
That's why,
you know,
I was always talking about children side.
I was always on guides.
That's interesting.
When I moved to New York,
I finally realized like any sort of racism,
like any fear based racism,
like I'm afraid of black people just became,
oh,
I'm just afraid of the youth.
Uh,
anyone young,
they're just rowdy and they pushy or they just shove,
they're more likely to shove and say something like settled down young man.
We were,
yeah,
we were talking about that in the previous podcast.
We were talking about the scariest thing my friend Eric,
they were crisp of sugar tree cues.
I think you met him before Eric.
Chris maybe.
What's the deal maker?
What city?
He lives in New Mexico.
Okay.
Um,
he said that teenage boys,
the scariest thing on earth do,
they don't know limits and they're getting strong,
you know,
like real cocky.
Just coming into their body is overwhelmed with like testosterone and Maria age
and a lot of their versions of the world are based on movies.
I'll fuck you up.
Come to me at that way.
I'll go,
I'll die for that.
Cause like really 17 year old,
I'm thinking,
well shit,
that makes you realize like,
oh,
you're just a child.
You're just a little boy who's like six feet tall.
You're this,
you're that.
Exactly.
They don't know.
At least 10 years old and you're really strong,
but you're out there running through the world like a big baby almost,
you know,
supervise baby.
Oh,
big strong,
unsupervised baby who's just learned and America's the best.
That's why fucking fight.
He was America's the best,
right America.
The one guy said it was I fucking off.
Fuck that bitch swallowed his chief health till learn like no.
Well actually at a point that he's trying to make.
No,
fuck you.
You didn't even hear his point out the point.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's the world we live in.
Arusha,
fear,
godly.
It's tough.
Tough to get it together.
So goddamn mad.
Race.
We're all deer with dealing with a,
uh,
a big spreadsheet of genetics that was sort of formulated back.
Boy Running.
Avoid them like barking doors.
Okay.
Get us in people's DNA.
Ari.
We're trapped in some 10,000 filed sugar and rape and drug ourselves.
Cold Syrup bought.
Did you ever get a hold of the real nyquil?
No.
You never got ahold of real nyquil.
He never took it.
No Man.
Didn't really fuck you.
Oh Man.
I remember,
look,
when I was on a news radio,
like in the late nineties,
um,
no,
I had never done any drugs.
I didn't do anything.
We can't say no.
He says that and you're like,
guys,
but it's not the way to the fucking top.
I thought it made you lazy.
No bullshit.
But um,
but this was a,
this was told her do things.
You're like,
oh,
I was wrong.
Let's go the other way.
Cause I was wrong.
I see.
That's what I said about when I was still a virgin in college.
I'm like,
guys,
it's the same as masturbating,
right?
It's not like it's the same.
You Orgasm,
that's the same as it feels the same.
And they're like,
oh man,
so wrong.
That's so funny.
It's so,
it feels considerably better.
Um,
what was I saying?
you still like the purple stuff?
No,
no,
no.
Don't make sure it's exactly what you're saying.
Oh,
rubbish.
It was,
um,
wasn't even robot Thompson was that other stuff.
I thank well the real Nyquil,
the real nyquil with coding.
So I wasn't doing anything.
I did occasionally I would drink,
but even then I'd feel guilty.
Very,
very,
very rarely would try weed.
You're not going to pull it all the time.
He never drank.
Not much.
Didn't really drink.
I was trying to be healthy,
you know,
that was like a fight or two year olds trying to,
trying to be healthy.
Okay.
I was just trying not be a loser.
Um,
you know what it is to be a loser per yard.
We just not be that.
Yeah.
What's enough to just scare off the wolves.
So you've never done drugs or alcohol?
Pretty much.
Okay.
I got sick and I just felt like total shit man.
I was just,
I got hit with the flu or whatever the fuck it was.
So I took some Nyquil and I felt so
relaxing.
It's codene man,
whatever it said to take,
I took more,
you know,
if it said the sake,
like if you weigh like up to 170 pounds,
Mike.
Yeah,
we're about one 90 and I probably weighed like one 69 but right above that I
took a fall.
I was lean son and have much fatty tissue.
I took a full dose once he's wearing,
took a ladle.
This nyquil fucked me up and I was,
I was deep in this pillow,
this down pillow and I felt so loved.
Really?
Oh my God.
If it was a love that felt like the universe,
she's just just rubbing me with love boy,
how it felt.
So what was in it?
What's in that to the old dean coding man.
Cody want drugs.
Coating.
It's a good one.
That's a drug.
That's the drawings.
What you used to take when you were a kid growing up before you would take like
one thing and he'd do it right before you go to bed.
You know like what can I find that you didn't give it still get it.
Go to your doctor's office,
coughing up before your doctor.
You get bronchitis,
you can get it.
You just need to start coffin.
Rough your throat up a little bit.
And how do they give it to you?
Now?
A pill form or something.
Like if you're going to turn your girlfriend into the car,
you got to turn your girlfriend and the cops for domestic abuse.
She'd punch yourself in the face a few times.
She gotta do to get the Cody and you've got to raspy up your throat.
Man,
I got to fuck it up.
You got a cough a lot and they go,
this poor,
poor gentleman needs some codes usually way worse.
I notice I'm braved it out because of this doctor appointment.
I'm barely breathing and they hook you up with that dude,
dude,
I got a scribe for a wisdom tooth out and my doctor,
both of them done really good job,
so it was like not really worried about this one.
He's like,
if you need these things,
if I could answer,
he goes,
if you don't need them,
I'm just goes.
I'm sure you can find maybe somebody,
I don't know.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm a comedian.
I have multiple people telling me to tough it out.
He said that,
let's say he allegedly,
so let's say that somebody could track your dental records.
Oh God.
It's like my friends did love it though.
Like you don't use those.
I'm like never been into them.
I'm like,
well you might be that.
That stuff you're talking about is what like all the,
like the celebrity kids mixed with like you know,
red bull and shit like that.
And they drink it as a drink.
It's like per called purple drink and stuff.
And that's all that,
although the Biebers and stuff that get caught with like the bottles of that
income.
What is the,
what's the mixture handler Sarah says or that's what they're drinking?
Codine Modine.
It's usually mixed with like mountain dew or something like that.
Or Wow.
Jolly ranchers.
There's a comedian,
I'm not going to name,
why don't you name names here that you fuck.
There's a comedian that used to have a real problem with Nyquil and club owners
would have to buy him like containers and bring them to him and he would drink
them like more than one a Dunkin.
And so he's a club owner and how to bring them
along time ago.
Wow.
Long time ago.
And that's why I had to bring it for him.
Fault and this guy.
That's pretty cool.
Well,
you know it's good.
Good,
good comics.
Well on it.
She's very good.
I don't know.
I don't think he was on,
it was on stage.
I think it's one of those things where you know you want to like fight the
demons on it and so at night you need some sort of chemical protection.
Take the coding and rally and
fight.
You see that guy?
Fuck yeah,
I did moment.
It came out.
I was first in line.
Oh,
nice hobby.
I love those movies,
man.
Dragons and those habits were such cool dragons the best.
I rooted for him to fucking douchebags quits talking songs all the time.
Idiot.
Yeah,
man.
Lay too happy with yourself.
Yeah.
Oh you're,
we're all love their am deaf.
Fucking dragon was so dope.
The Cgi they can do together.
Oh my God.
I don't know how many people are working together on that thing,
but the CGI that they were able to concoct what they're able to do really good.
Oh my God.
It's so good.
It does.
It looks like it's a real thing.
And there's another real thing that's interacting with like the CGI.
So good.
Especially with dragons because dragons aren't real.
So you don't know what they really look like.
Oh right.
You're kind of like use video wild.
But if you look at like a dog,
like when they CGI dogs,
it just looks slightly goofy.
They're just a slight goofiness to haven't totally overcome yet.
But they've overcome it with dragons and also with dinosaurs they don't move
quite right.
It's like what's your fucking why you move along that dog?
No,
I think hair is a big one.
Yeah.
And Harris tough to reproduce.
I think they have a real hard time like making like accurate looking ripples and
stuff like that because it's all done with programs and they have to use all
these like various technologies to figure out how to fucking shade things
correctly and use the proper textures.
And it's like,
it's really quite slowly.
So your general look at those when like normal.
Well,
you know,
Clay Guido couldn't be in the early UFC games because he wouldn't cut his hair,
his hair down.
So Clegg weed.
His hair was so important to him that he chose to not be in the early UFC
instead of cut it.
Yeah,
because he's like,
they will,
I mean,
I don't know if anybody ever pull that hair and just yank it down or to fight.
You're not allowed to.
They're not allowed.
You used to be able to do that.
In fact,
hoists Gracie use chemos hair,
like it was a really important part of him.
He was beating the shit out of him from his back and then he set up an arm bar.
Wow.
But hoists was holding on to his ponytail like he had a grip on the back of his
head.
Like is ridiculous to give someone the ability to hold on to the back of your
hair if that's like a part of fighting Eric Paulson,
he's another guy who got in a bad situation because the guy was grabbing his
hair and punched him in the head.
Like,
you know,
I was like,
oh,
you can't have hair like this.
If this is for five,
it's easy to grab onto the handle in your head,
son.
It's like my bit about the fucking,
the,
the duck hunting guys.
The duck dynasty guys and their beard.
Oh man that thinks there.
Unless somebody wants to fuck your face.
That's the goddamn handle right there.
Who?
Buffalo.
This is the best way you gave them a handle to hold onto your mouth.
What are you trying to do?
Leaving it open for me.
Yeah,
but what they can do it with,
um,
with dinosaurs and they can do it with dragons.
Great.
Real tragic park.
Had a great,
the first Tresor park.
Fuck you can watch on TV now.
He can watch it too because it looks terrible on the screen.
That was awesome.
Yeah,
I saw the new trailer.
it looks amazing.
Why would they go back there ever?
Why do they keep going back 10 years later?
That's it.
What it is though?
Or is it a total reboot?
Like A,
I don't know.
I feel like it's a reboot.
Like Spiderman,
like they're either going back or they're going back and see it on that.
There's like a map.
You can see the quarantine zone.
Like you're not supposed to go here and fix the rest of the shit.
Okay.
Oh,
I wish we could play that.
Can we can we can play it on this TV trailer?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
I hope it's in three d because I will already be running.
Yeah,
I don't think it will definitely will not be greedy trailers that we can
probably go blind by the end of the show.
Please find the class.
Does anybody feel uncomfortable?
Or is it just me?
It's a little bit uncomfortable getting out.
Maybe we should go without the glasses.
So they're going back.
Can we get some volume?
Yep.
So we'll listen to this.
Oh three birds over my head.
All the,
Oh,
you have tweety birds who put tweety birds over?
Said Birds.
It's rude
if someone chases you or something.
10 years ago they were killing people.
Don't joke about it.
Well,
we joke about Hiroshima.
It's true.
So what?
We're watching people that are listening at home is a super dope yacht headed
towards an island that is populated and this little fucking kid pushes the frog
so you can just say not everyone else was watching.
What'd your dad fuck face?
Push it up front.
Can I get some manners?
You little cunt.
White privileged little CIS privilege.
White privilege.
CIS gendered gathering some balls.
Little suppressive asshole.
Now they're in these um,
trains and pots and they're just casually strolling around dinosaurs and then
it's zero.
Yeah,
there's a shark suspended
and an impossibly huge dinosaur comes out of the water,
eats the shark.
Wow.
And ruins everyone's iPhones.
And you know what I realized when I look at that,
you got to feed that fucker.
A lot of sharks.
How many sharks?
Nothing needed day.
A lot.
Price is way bigger than the shark.
Okay.
I doubt they planned this awesome science shit.
Somebody super hot scientists for no reason.
I believable.
It's a super hot with bangs.
It was that Brad,
she's hot as fuck.
That guy's hot as fuck to this.
I was just wished this would turning the guardians of Galaxy too.
I haven't seen the first one yet because you're an idiot.
Oh,
how dare you.
That's a good movie.
Is a handsome bastard right there.
Also deer hunter.
Evacuate the island.
Look how pretty that girls there,
Ireland,
would you be willing to give it all up?
The whole Hollywood dream just to be in her arms in the rest of your life?
In harmony
every day.
Oh Wow.
Why are you saying I don't like this back?
She said,
run
decker away.
Ooh,
I love the sound.
Oh,
good Lord.
The racing against who I swear out this wall and the velociraptors are running
right past and you from what it is,
they're all going to get killed him and some crazy super dinosaur.
It's a new super dinosaur.
Yeah,
like regular dinosaurs weren't funky enough for sure.
The the giant one,
they fed the sharks too.
That's coming back into play later.
That's not going to only be a plot point.
They're going to hit once.
I definitely going to be like disagree.
Really.
It can be it.
Yeah.
That's very possible.
That's it.
I don't think it is.
My pet said is not.
I think it's probably really expensive film,
Underwater Shit.
And they're like,
look,
we could stick to the jungles.
We could save about 75 million from the budget.
No way they're going to do it all.
[inaudible] brand has this underwater technology down pat.
He's the only guy right now because the avatar two and he's deep sea diving and
knowing the reg,
right?
Yeah.
Yes.
That's goes down.
He goes down to the bottom of the fucking old records
him.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Nuts.
He goes to the bottom of the ocean and he like innovates.
He like,
he's like one of those guys that's involved in the innovation as far as like
deep sea filming and exploration.
And he's going down in the little one man submarines and shit like,
oh,
that's where he's gonna die.
He's gonna die in one of those things.
Maybe not,
maybe not even more incredible.
We get through all this and he's fine.
You know,
you get to see the depths of the fucking where no one has ever been a keys.
He's got enough money to do it correctly.
God.
I mean,
he's incredibly wealthy and begins a wife.
It's like with your next time,
you don't think I might have seen that stuff.
That's how annoying his wife is.
He goes to the bottom of the ocean.
They don't away.
Or could you imagine if that's what he said.
Can you imagine James Cameron?
Why did you go to the bottom of the ocean?
Cause my wife won't shut the fuck up.
That was his post game interview.
We're not saying it is Mr. Cameron.
Please,
please don't hack our plan.
We're humble servants of the Lord the overlord.
We love you.
I'm a huge James Cameron Fan.
I love that fucking movie.
He does cool stuff.
Not just that one level.
1 million of his movie.
God damn well want to pull up as I am.
They're making two SQL to Avatar,
right?
No Way.
Yeah.
Avatar to an avatar three is that what every brilliant two of them.
He's done so many movies,
man.
Um,
yeah,
he did aliens right in a terminator movies
and he married,
he married the girl from the terminator movies.
Right.
Damn,
I'm going to fuck my star.
Never find a whole lot.
What?
How dare you fuck.
Take a lap.
Taking a lab.
I'll stand by it.
She's dating sex.
Oh,
she's so sexy.
She's tough.
Survivor,
Bro.
Three new avatar movies.
She's,
wow.
Three News.
There's going to be four of them total.
Yep.
Damn,
motherfucker did titanic.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Titanic and aliens.
You know I had a problem with aliens and I still do monster.
What's the only reason I have
a problem with this because I saw alien aliens is all of a sudden they became
dopey and easy to kill.
Alien.
The first one.
He's incredibly smart and slick.
Avoiding people.
Yeah,
and he finds a way to ambush you when you're,
you're,
you're not looking to turn around and he's
always doing the movies.
They think scale wrong so that you can murder a town.
Thousand people trying to stop you,
but then one guy,
it's like difficult.
Just that one alien was that bad of an ass.
He was a newborn with no one to teach them the problem.
We no one to teach him.
Right.
He's the one who escaped out of the fucking belly and ran off.
That's a good point.
You're really living on his own.
That's beautiful.
You're right.
They wouldn't talk on his own.
He figured that out.
Maybe what we would do the fence.
I'm going to let him fix the alien populations.
Get them together like when they're really young and feed them only vegetables.
Oh,
you're right.
Turn them into vegans.
Change though.
Just give him beans.
Beans are fine.
There's a lot of routine.
The alien,
the alien.
We have a bowl of beans.
It fucking slammed his head to the door.
Try to try to kill you.
Keep it in some sort of a cell.
We have your be
fuck you.
Fuck God damn slim I can say are going to be Vegan.
They've should be Vegan by now.
It's this wigs you go to.
Try to get your,
your retrade retrieved and his fucking teeth mark in it.
Big Shark Bites.
Sick.
Go get vegetables,
Mr Alien.
Okay.
I'm not giving you anything but mashed potatoes and sweet potatoes and yams and
Vegan butter guy.
This guy,
he knows.
They just claws clawing every day for 16 hours,
clawing at the door.
Eventually they'll get calm and stuff.
Just Stereo,
just like they have to bring an engineer's to figure out when they're going to
get tired.
They don't seem to be any in tired.
If we get,
we should love the last year,
give him some meat.
All about the vaping experience.
I guide
of it.
That'd be a good sequel to alien Ellie and the Vegan.
You imagine if something like
please take one right,
right out of the chest.
It explodes into a tube.
Like we have the two set up on the guy's chest.
We know he's going to give birth to the right when it breaks through a
breakthrough in the world.
One of those vacuum things,
the over those hills lots.
Yeah,
the mail slot,
those fucking things.
Sure.
That's the best way to get an abortion.
I met Jamie and I were looking at another,
uh,
a warehouse space and one of the spaces like podcast studio space,
one of the spaces had,
well,
those things in it,
it's still there,
open the cap.
He still worked in it and close it?
Well,
we don't know.
I mean,
we don't know if it worked,
but they had a thing there.
I had one of those fucking launcher things.
Cool.
And then people just knew he just went to the right place.
I there was like a,
I guess there was a destination on the other end,
like they had it mailed the mail room.
I don't know.
I mean I don't,
I think it might've been the place that we were looking at.
They did to all sorts of weird experiments.
So I don't know what the fuck kind of weird shit that we're doing inside there.
They were doing like missile technology.
Yeah.
We looked at like warehouses where they'd previously done like missile
technology shit.
They probably wouldn't even supposed to tell us that.
Right.
Probably those motherfuckers probably violated some sort of a constitutional
amendment.
We all start getting like knee cancer from just being there being cancer.
Yeah.
But they had a tube.
They had one of those.
Wow.
That's fun.
Yeah.
I would stick my hand in all the time.
Hold it back.
Of course.
Eventually w Dick in there,
right with a fleshlight was saw the bottom off of fleshlight or unscrew it and
just pure suction.
Oh yeah,
I'll just suctions.
Someone's going to do it like it's pulling you back.
Yeah,
definitely do.
It might be built perfectly for imagined if no one knew.
But then like you get like the standard like mail slot vacuum thing and you put
a flashlight to and you're like,
oh my God,
look at this.
Schunk we just like locks in place.
Like funk like this.
This is like,
cause it's like,
it's like Indiana Jones where you like put the right thing into the wall.
Turn the key and the make it work.
Oh,
but then the worst part about that is after you calm,
it would get shut up that fucking slot
into somebody's office and just catch her fucking facial.
No,
it goes right into the ocean and it feeds the fish.
It's biodegradable.
Oh,
there's all set up just for that.
Totally.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
You're building infrastructure.
Yeah,
it's in Malibu.
It's the same house that they used to film iron man.
We're just coming on dolphin.
Dolphins swimming in it and love the vacuum tubes leading out into the ocean.
Good Lord.
Yeah.
If somebody came up with something like that,
you know,
have you seen the latest stuff they're doing with oculus rift?
Not Wearing an oculus rift?
First Person Porn.
They're doing three d Marilyn know.
Yeah.
Virtual reality.
You have stuff on you.
It's kind of like touch you and stuff.
Not yet right now it's just you're watching it and you're watching it and it
looks like you're actually doing it.
Yeah.
But eventually they're going to be able to sync that up with something that
stimulates your senses.
You still haven't watched South Park Oculus rift episode,
have you?
No,
I have not got a Watson off this whole season of south park.
It's an amazing season.
Will help to guys don't watch one episode walked as the first season where the
whole season holds together as one.
It's like a movie lines start at the beginning.
Yes.
It's,
I'm guilty of not watching South Park.
I'm really guilty.
I need to get on it.
Is it on Netflix too?
Uh,
I dunno.
It was like South Park studios is on an apple TV.
It's on Hulu Plus Hulu plus.
It's probably on the,
on the comedy central.
It's south park studios.com up there.
Well comedy central you,
you,
you use an htmi
and to get it to you or the comedy central direct or CC [inaudible] dot com
[inaudible] dot com that though,
don't they have like their own like apple TV and then they have,
they have their own effects.
If you have an iPad or an iPhone and you just use that happen.
The UFC has an APP now too in the,
um,
if you're doing an apple TV,
yeah,
they have an APP.
Like you got an apple TV and go to the UFC.
Dot TV.
You can go and watch the fight.
Fight Pass is available.
Yeah.
Dude,
I was watching the other day.
I was bored and I just said,
let me just watch some old fights.
And I've watched like two hours of old fights.
It just,
Kevin,
when choosing different fights,
he went running diesel,
all those old,
all the,
each have their own symbol,
whatever on the,
whatever the fucking devices.
I haven't watched TV on a regular TV for her.
What did they have those things up there?
We can go to the Netflix one and the FX and little icons.
You Click.
Yeah,
yeah,
and he goes,
they all just have their live HBO girl.
They all have their own live feed and you just appletv it until the TV,
apple TV is incredible.
The other thing,
once he goes grab them is live sports.
But now that I've got that,
you can watch live Fox live,
CBS,
it's eventually going to happen.
It's,
I mean,
why wouldn't they just get what you want to get?
Don't get it.
You don't want to get it to have it all available to everyone.
The regular television networks is going to be obsolete.
There's almost no way around it.
It's just too difficult to support that sort of model when someone can do
something like Netflix where they can have the entire season up in advance and
events.
When you ready to hear it all is,
this is Marco Polo.
I'm watching,
you know,
have you seen it?
It's not a part of it.
It's fucking good dude.
And the entire season is in advance.
You just download the whole season.
He why'd he had been watch from the jump.
I mean it's fucking great.
They've got a good bottle.
Ah,
there's so they're killing it,
but they have like some insane amount of people that have subscribed because it
kept putting a good product in worldwide and 70 million people paying seven
bucks a month.
That's a lot of fucking people,
man.
That's insane that the money's insane.
They gotta keep putting it back in to look at and make a new shows and stuff.
Yeah.
Tammy,
same cards,
show cards and also standup specials.
They're great for standup specials.
Netflix,
they,
my first one,
uh,
my,
my first legit one was,
I did it for Netflix then put it on showtime.
That was 2005 I was old Netflix.
They were always doing things like that though.
They've done a lot that the bill burr ones,
they did the black and white one from Atlanta.
It's for my special can be seen this Friday.
How many central midnight,
11:00 PM if you're in the middle zones,
but he didn't get it right now.
Right?
Are you good right now?
Go to Ari shapiro.com or the great.com wait,
what are you saying?
It's right there.
It's available right now for download.
Hold on.
What don't you understand?
Oh,
okay.
Hold on.
Let's back up.
So Joe,
can,
we asked questions about that,
that you can get your special right now@alreadythegreat.com and it's not even
being uncommon.
Essential.
Yes,
that's right.
It's not even been on comedy central.
And you'll get the bigger version,
the 30 extra minutes that is fucking outrageous.
And a joy a yes.
Yeah.
The [inaudible] peninsula.
That is outrageous.
Have you ever seen the [inaudible]?
No.
Um,
yeah,
of course I have.
Man.
I've been there seven times.
The back of the comedy store.
I ask you,
you a question to a question.
It was just fun.
It was there before it was a Jew and a,
or somebody came up with like,
and that's shorter.
The Q and a juvenile.
Yeah.
It was weird watching you a film that there,
that was one of the first days I ever came back.
I came back the day before that to watch the roast battle.
Unless you're used to just like,
I don't make a big deal.
You're special if we just get it out of the way now and then I go,
yeah,
yeah.
I wanted it to be,
um,
I want to just to see your special,
take it in,
not as someone like I can't believe I'm at the store the very first time back
years and I'm seeing it already special being filmed.
I wanted to get that out of the way.
So I got that out of the way first and I just,
um,
it was so weird seeing you up there doing your special like killing it.
Oh thanks.
It was a,
it was why weird?
Well not weird.
Like unexpected.
It just,
just surreal and so many different ways.
No one you,
as long as I've known you knowing you when you really first started doing it,
he wants to be on that stage fucking as a terrible new comic.
Well as a smart open miker that had potential.
That's what I felt.
Super Green Anyway.
Yeah,
but I thought you'd be fine.
I remember the moment I first started talking to y'all,
I was like,
this guy can do it.
Like all you have to do is just keep going like this.
I knew you were smart and you were funny and you know you were young and we were
all young and awkward,
but you were,
you had an idea.
Like if you had an idea,
you could say we could be all talking and you would say something and people go,
yeah,
you know,
and that's all you need.
Then you have to be able to draw from that.
But I knew you were smart and I knew you were,
you know,
you were pretty driven to be a standup comic.
Like you really wanted it.
I knew you were going to make it.
I knew he was going to make it.
It was just one of those things I didn't,
no,
no one can.
I mean that's,
that's just what it's all about.
I mean that's also part of what drives you to put in the work that takes you to
make it.
We all know guys that started out at the same time.
It's you that were really talented,
are gone like you were.
They had the same like kind of potential that you had.
You know,
there's a lot of them,
I don't even want to mention names because I want to hear him.
I don't want them to hear this podcast to be bummed out and overall things went
on.
They didn't go on to become professional comedians even.
They just kind of got a job somewhere and they never figured out how to follow
through.
But there's a few guys that we could talk about off air,
so God damn good.
They were really good.
They had to watch their sets.
But I think that's for the,
for the guys who do get through it,
a stern warning,
like don't,
don't think you're special.
Like don't think you can ever relax.
Don't think you can ever take time off of analyzing what you're doing and making
sure that you're doing it right.
Don't take it for granted.
Don't take the audience for granted,
ever.
Don't,
you know,
just,
well,
every level of development somebody dropped off.
So even somebody who's like how to hit,
you know,
special and then it's like,
then they drop off their,
someone else has a one good open mic joke drop off.
They are like at every level you're going to have it have however many people,
10 people at that level and it's going to drop off to three that makes it to the
next level.
We can all crash and burn.
Yeah.
You know,
one of the things is really any kind of is me,
you know,
one of the things that really excited me about being back at the comedy store
and also,
um,
like,
like deciding that I'm going to stay in La for awhile is that like this,
this area that we have now,
like the,
the amount of,
uh,
like cool places to work,
amount of cool comics,
amount of funny guys that are in this area that we're at right now.
This is really rare.
This is really,
this is a rare spot,
man.
You know,
we were doing,
we've done some of these shows at the ice house.
Last one we did,
I think it was you and bill burr and Joey Diaz and Brian Cowen and Ian Edwards.
And we're sitting around and where I was like,
this is the fucking most murderous lineup I've ever seen in my life and nothing,
I don't know when it says,
and we're all,
we all live here,
you know,
we all drive here a Wednesday night,
a hug each other,
smoke some joints,
you know,
and Brian,
Brian's doing the icehouse chronicles is getting millions of downloads out of
the same spot.
You know,
you're going up there and,
and,
and you're killing it in front of this crazy Pasadena crowd to know about
comedy.
These are crazy shows,
man.
I mean,
these are shows that are just like me and math.
We're always got into a fight over like la or in New York who has better comics.
But then I've always pointed like guys,
like it's like you developed their best ones and then shipped them off to us.
So like we're the Yankees.
There's no fucking,
we have to know the team there is no best,
it doesn't matter.
There's no,
it's all bullshit.
Like the idea of arguing about that.
There's two good environments for standup at all.
You know,
I think one of the advantages that you have coming from the La Model,
which has less clubs,
less sets,
so the New York model,
which is more clubs,
more sets,
more travel,
you're hopping back and forth from Club to club is that you,
you're,
you're coming from two different perspectives and I think that I like to both
adamantly.
Yeah.
Like the boat.
There's,
there's weaknesses that each one has and they just can deal with it cause it's
that they're used to that scene.
Yeah.
I feel like your jokes per your,
your laughs per joke,
the tightness of your joke has beginning become cleaner since you went to New
York.
Yeah.
In New York there's a lot of like,
come on,
get to it,
got through it,
you know?
Yeah.
I think that's a good thing to have.
But then also senator with something else where it's not all about like an
ironic level of just here's my writing joke,
you know,
they have a lot of that where it's not so much truthful is more like here's a
good joke about a thing.
Well,
what I was going to say is I think that the combination of Combo brought from
the your experience in La and on the road and then going to New York,
like that's a good mixture.
And I think that ultimately that that's all you could want as a comic is like,
I think one of the things that's really important for all of us,
it seems to be important when I watch other people do it when I'm outside of it
is live experiences equal funny equals perspective equals funny.
Like the more experiences you're having in your life,
the more material you're going to have.
You know?
And I mean experiences like go do something like go somewhere,
go do something,
go try something out.
Like bill burrs bit about,
uh,
go get your heartbeat in a helicopter pilot.
If you ever seen that bit and just get this new band special about learning how
to fly a helicopter.
I'm not saying anything more because it's just that it's that fucking good that
I don't want to ruin any of it.
I won't ruin it by saying the word helicopter,
so I'll leave it at that.
But it's one of my all time favorite bits and it's a bit that he developed by
actually doing that,
by actually learning how to fly a helicopter and he actually can fly.
So I think that doing,
she's got a dog or that whole joke,
but like watch people cross the street,
he's coming up.
I was like,
yeah,
like the power.
He's got a lot of great jokes,
but it's,
it's living a little,
yeah.
Living,
experiencing life,
doing that too.
Yeah.
It's a whole different scene in New York.
Uh,
not just like the comics while I'm talking about the girls in the bars and the
way you walk instead of drive.
Yeah,
just a new experience in general.
Like you get your fucking mind moving,
it gets everything fired up in a new way.
And I mean even if you don't want to move somewhere,
I mean tried Jujitsu,
do something weird like different route to work everyday.
Try Surfing,
learn how to surf lesson and get out there and the in shark infested waters.
Santa Monica [inaudible] lifeline was like,
I lie.
He just told her I need to blot out the little Dum,
Dum,
Dum.
I worked this out in 10 countries.
There's material.
Oh,
that's interesting man.
I went to a bunch of different places and try as much as I could.
Well,
you did a lot of comedy in China and we talked about in the last time you are
hearing with all that gutter oil stuff.
The last time I was here in June and July when I got back,
I was wearing,
when I got back from China,
it was it the last time?
I think so man,
you might've been here in between.
It's hard to tell.
Oh yeah.
Maybe I might go to share the type of special could be,
yeah,
I think you were doing comedy there for like a specific type of people.
It's like,
oh,
interesting.
All right.
Some stuff works.
I'm still,
does it,
do,
do they just go to see anybody who comes there every week?
Yeah,
they know about it.
A lot of them would,
but did it,
he'll read like this comics in town.
He'd be,
people seem to like him to be like,
oh,
maybe I'll go,
well,
he's pretty cool if you're in a spot.
If someone figures out a way to get really good comics to fly out all the way to
Singapore.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Form in front of you.
Like that's gotta be pretty fun.
Yeah.
Brent wind doctors got back.
Dude.
So weird and funny.
Yeah.
He's very funny though.
I really enjoy watching him.
Yeah.
It's just outside the box.
Well,
we were saying it's like this is a great time.
There's someone needs,
there's so many good comments right now.
This is like maybe the best time of all time.
There's a bunch of good people doing good stuff and you're like,
yeah,
cool man.
Cool.
Yeah.
Like if you take yourself out of the manners,
yeah.
Take yourself out and then judge and says,
look at the system.
Like they'll go shows.
There's so many shows and there's also like the ability to promote oneself
through the internet.
It's gotten to this point where you get to know people that me might have,
like you know we,
we've about many times about a Robin Harris who was like a really funny black
comic back in the 90s he died before anybody got to know who he was,
but he didn't really have the distribution who was in later a couple of movies
he did like a little bit,
he had a CD called babies kids,
but he was just so God damn good man at the time.
But for whatever reason,
the distribution method just wasn't available for him at the time and it's,
it's,
it's available now.
It's way better.
That's available now.
You can just find her.
That's why there's no squabbling over there.
Brian,
what are you doing?
I was just trying to get my sweatshirt.
That's what,
there's no giant bands anymore.
It looks like you're on fire because you don't need a Beatles for everybody.
You would just need very specific things for very specific audiences.
Dave math.
So they break it down further and further and he's like,
you don't have to like Dave Matthews band.
You can like a little bit more of an upbeat tape.
Math has been,
well guess what?
There's nine bands that are playing that type of music right now and you can
find all of them.
You don't have to wait for the radio to bring it to you.
That's a very good point.
So if you don't,
can't get these massive stars anymore.
Do you think that's true though?
I mean,
how does,
how's it Justin Bieber in marriage?
Is He kids music kids music?
Yeah.
The only way it works,
and he was still through those distribution methods.
Kids don't download shit.
Yeah.
I think that's probably best for everybody that doesn't know giant stars.
I think all,
yeah.
I mean there's a lot of people that essentially should be giant stars that for
whatever reason don't get considered in the same breath as like Jim Morrison or
Janis Joplin or dead people.
Right?
Like,
okay,
Chris Cornell,
Chris Cornell from Soundgarden,
maybe one of the greatest vocalists of all time.
It was great,
dude,
he's a monster.
He's still around and right.
Of course he is,
but I mean,
if you,
like,
if you looked at like people who people like worship as being like all time
greats,
for whatever reason,
that guy likes slips through the cracks,
you know?
Yeah,
you're right.
Right.
You know,
some people just hold up and some people don't,
and you talk about 20 years later that guy's out may listen to spoon man.
You know,
when that guy had the most insane voice,
his voice is incredible.
Did you hear the guy took over for him?
Was that that band or the other band?
Who's the blackout to go for the white guy?
Give it to me,
Brian.
The black guy that took over for the white pie by white,
by down in a hole.
He was laying down in a hole.
Oh,
uh,
it's all,
it's not Allison black guy took over after I got a new lead singer.
He's laying Stanley sides.
Exactly like lions daily.
Exactly.
Like lines daily,
and you forget the fact that it's not Layne Staley until he sinks down in a
hole.
All right?
We realize we're going to play a little game of Youtube Roulette.
Yeah.
Cause you tell,
let's see if we get kicked off youtube by playing this.
Oh,
you think it can help you too by playing it?
Why are we get kicked off all the time?
Why so?
I Dunno.
It just happens.
So,
uh,
let's see.
Let's play it.
Let's free information right at my body.
What's it called?
I have to find something with him and singing it.
Okay.
What's,
what's homeboy's name?
Uh,
look.
William Deval.
I it.
William Duvall.
Yeah.
Oh well let's just find out like some of their new shit.
He sounds just like,
he thinks the old name silly.
He doesn't seem like that doesn't look that black.
He is blogs like Sephardic
notice I use that a really safe as the way to really articulate term Sephardic.
Think there's,
I'm more cultured.
Thank you.
He's a semite my gain in the box.
That's the guy now that's a white guy with a guitar player.
That guy looks like he does math.
Wow.
Jerry Cantrell.
Listen,
you should be in a fucking Nickelback.
Where is the black one?
Bring him to me.
He's so like,
he's so happy with life and everything else,
so it's tough to believe like that.
He can actually sing about heroin.
Oh yeah.
Lights.
The only song going to buy from him,
dem bones,
dem bones thinks it all big.
Oh Wow.
Damn Bounds.
All that guy's back now you realize.
Yeah,
I love that.
Different angles like,
oh,
that's got a lag as fuck.
That was not the same dude.
At some point,
I got to hear what this dude sound.
Got to hear it.
Just fast forward.
Born again,
1998 but listen,
this is Layne Staley then this isn't the the black gentleman,
I don't know yet.
He's think it's both actual liens.
Stanley died.
He died in 2002
the band is signage to reunite for a benefit concert.
That was the starting point for a new beginning of Alice in chains.
14 years.
They released a new album lead singer Wm to evolve.
Well,
what is this?
Why am I reading this?
Jamie?
Can I hear this gentleman saying where's yeah,
just fast forward a minute.
Where's the black guy?
Yeah,
you guys ready?
Putting Simmons,
what the fuck?
Kind of fuckery.
That's the guy who looked like him.
So it's about their journey.
Well that's not dude singing.
I don't know.
This is bullshit.
I want to hear it.
This is probably your biggest failure your brother had here.
I just,
I want to say as an artist,
as an artist,
artists to artists,
shut up about your fucking journey.
You're not a hobbit.
Okay.
Your goddamn singer in a rock and roll band.
I know what you're doing,
bitch.
How dare.
Yeah.
Right.
They still overdo that.
I'm fucking shut up it river.
How dare you are the journey.
I had to take my own guitar case.
Yeah,
just my room for a top boots tied up with fucking sin.
You remember,
did your hike over the hill?
Dsa guys with leather pants and Hollywood's like a day when it's hot out.
He's like,
it's the only path they own.
Pair their fucking show pants,
but they're honest shit and I was melting inside ball bag.
Said Moran in there.
It's cooking.
It's like a fucking severe.
Jay Jimmy,
this is the second video.
I'm on.
Jamie come on two and I know,
my God,
this is Jamie's been top five William Deval songs.
Last couple of,
wow,
that looks weird with the three d glasses on.
I'm not happy with these.
Made a generally positive number.
Okay,
we get it.
We get sounds like a white guy.
Yeah.
Sounds like but yeah we got it.
How's your ball's been Ari?
Everything downstairs cause we never tried to you about your,
your balls and your buds and stuff like that.
Thought I had herpes.
Oh that's right.
Really positive.
I had herpes.
I mean really positive.
Like what was the symptom log on to one is 10 10 I was a nine I go,
it's like fuck.
Well I got herpes,
the Sims is where I saw a scab on my dick and I was like,
well that's,
and then I looked it up on Google on images.
What else do you think it is?
Herpes,
herpes,
herpes scars or whatever.
Herpes outbreaks and it didn't look like most of them.
It looked about like one out of like 10 of them.
My case,
never had them before,
but I was like,
look,
I'm not the most careful guy in the world.
Okay.
I mean condoms,
condoms.
Uh,
so I was like,
well look,
it's caught up to me.
I guess this is,
this is fucking,
you know,
get it now.
It's better than I got on one of 25.
I wish right now we could play.
Damn,
it feels good to be a gangster
in 10 different countries.
At least I was in a bunch of countries.
And I was like,
look,
this could have happened at any point,
but I narrowed it down to who I thought he probably was.
I called like three or four girls or girls.
Hey,
I think I've herpes,
uh,
you should,
you should go get tested and stop fucking Damon.
Like,
why am I,
I have a outbreak,
I have a herpes out,
but there's no way there's anything else.
I have a herpes outbreak.
Yeah.
Cause what else could it be?
You just don't wake up and have a scab.
Exactly.
And,
um,
so I scheduled the blood work,
got everything taken care of and in the meantime we can know what's going to
take us.
It's over Christmas weekend so it's going to take longer.
Yeah.
And then while I was hanging out,
I was hanging out the stand.
How many club?
Maybe the best club in New York.
Okay.
But I'm talking to the owner and Pete Lee,
this comedian and tell him my problem.
And Pete was like,
you know I,
where is it like right underneath the hood of Your Dick?
I'm like,
yeah,
right there.
He's like,
I had something like this once.
It was like a penile tear.
Have you done anything like rough lately?
And I was like,
yeah,
actually I noticed it right after unlubricated anal sex.
That's when I first noticed it,
but it just didn't go away.
And lucky you're alive.
I'm lucky I'm alive.
And that's what it turned out to be.
How do you have unlubricated anal sex?
That's like fucking hard,
bro.
Hard.
I know.
Spit you didn't spit on the task force was wet.
It was wet course.
Lame Duck.
And that jug is played.
Yeah.
You get it wet and then you fucking go for it.
I don't know this,
but yeah,
what you gotta do,
but you just don't believe it's commercial lubricant.
So relieved.
Yeah.
And I'm telling you,
if you think your wife has been happy when you've called before,
after fucking three days on the road and not being able to call,
you've never heard.
You tell a girl,
oh,
I was wrong.
You don't have herpes.
They get elated overcome with joy.
Now do you think maybe you should have just waited till the results came back
showing these guys and he just didn't want him to fuck somebody else in the
meantime.
And then while I'm waiting to decide some other guy's life was ruined.
Right?
Well,
I heard this is there's will suck it up and take my lumps also on the other
level,
I figured I could tell them I'm 90% sure it was like a cop out.
So I'm not like fully sag.
Look at habit.
We fucked.
I thought that,
uh,
from what I understood when I got tested was that you can only test herpes while
the outbreaks happen.
Then the act actually spoon a little out of the outbursts that you can't really,
it's really hard to test for herpes,
so a lot of times you can get tested during like not an outbreak and be like,
oh yeah,
and then want to just positive for herpes.
I think it was an old tests.
I think that was like 15 years ago.
Toast.
They need Olympic style or if he's tough,
serious,
overcome his boy and throw in.
I heard if you do pop it like you could actually taste it.
It tastes purpose.
It's like a sweetness.
How many different fucking puss wounds before herpes is like,
I got it.
Yeah.
You can't just say it once.
That much of the that was solving young bloke
had it for a while and treat it.
It's a burgundy.
Burgundy is the wrong
culture.
Swiffer around like a penis in your hand.
Looking at next time that hoopy [inaudible] how many herpes is you have to build
a taste to be able to taste.
They figured out a way to train.
Yeah.
Dogs to smell cancer.
That's awesome.
That's pretty great.
You're telling me they can't put a dog at the fucking TSA counter smell for
bombs.
Yeah,
but they also were going to smell for weed.
No,
only trained the smell for bombs.
What about the weed dog?
He needs a job to get him and fucking the Miami airport.
All the wee dog,
he fucks up.
He thinks it's a bomb,
but it's really just weed.
The poor guy.
We try to train him.
Listen man,
we don't want to send them to the pound.
Sorry.
Let's just take a few,
you know,
one or two we'd arrest some months.
Not going to hurt anybody.
You know,
we're going to get more revenue in the system.
We're going to have
[inaudible] on our rights just for your right to raise money.
And
you know what?
Sometimes out of that struggle comes to dialogue.
No,
that's
important.
People.
Buzzwords.
Cops don't stop.
Don't just rob our freedom.
They don't just say the children for a little while,
24 hours.
Maybe you'll snap them.
I'll tell you what.
My friend's son,
the kid was a Ne'er do well.
He started going to jail and he got out of jail.
He realized,
I don't want to go to jail anyway.
No,
that's not a reason to search every he American.
He got back on the fucking right track.
No,
no,
no.
I'm sorry.
OPS and Jerry government.
You're not giving me good reasons.
Punched
him in the stomach and I brought him to the Lord.
If you seen that video.
No,
you want to see something?
Sure.
Pull that.
If you want to see something,
great.
Pull that video and then get ready.
Bonnie.
A white princess money princess bunnies.
This money.
Oh,
you talking about he about to see something that's going to disturb you.
See,
before that you want to see a guy punch a guy in the stomach.
See that?
Yeah.
He says,
pastor,
I was on my,
yeah,
pastor punches kid in the chest.
Look it.
See me as soon as he starts writing pastor,
that's where it shows up.
It's one of the first,
uh,
that's it right there.
This is sober day.
Felix young man.
His name was Ben.
I mean this is really ridiculous.
I was there for a few years.
He was just,
he was a nice kid,
but he was one of those kids.
It was always just,
it's a real smart Alec.
Oh,
what's a bright kid,
which didn't help things,
right.
Made it more dangerous.
We were outside one day youth group and he was just trying to push my buttons
and he was just,
you know,
kind of not taking the lord serious.
And I walked over to him and I went,
Bam.
I punched him in the chest as hard as I cropped the kid.
What'd you put them on the chat?
Just crumpled them.
And I said,
I leaned over and I said,
Ben,
when are you going to stop playing games with God?
I let that man to the Lord right there
sit that might be needed.
He didn't give a good example of,
oh,
what are you talking about?
The guy was just being a smart Alec [inaudible] had to leave,
just punched a kid and he was smart.
But that's bad.
It was,
he was smart.
What a chump that guy is.
I love the word chump.
Wow.
Just a straight jerk.
Oh my God.
Punched him as hard as he could in the chest.
You punched a little boy at youth camp and I said,
beg crumpled them.
Oh really?
When are you gonna take the Lord?
Serious
three tick.
What was he making jokes wasn't Ari.
He wasn't taking the Lord seriously.
It's being smart.
Alec
punched him.
That's a grown adult.
It's a grown man who's a teaching people leading people.
He's got a microphone on.
Christianity should be illegal.
It all should be illegal.
Anybody telling you they know the answer should be arrested and you know they're
not.
That's false advertising.
They should all be arrested,
man.
You can't put on on food.
Even this crooked FDA,
you kept on food.
Tons of nutrients without any proof of nutrients kind of do that.
That's so true though.
Drew can't just say,
oh no,
no,
I know the answer.
It's like we could you show us how you do it all or you're just making it up and
taken photos of money.
So we just show me,
Yo,
you proof of this.
When Adam and Eve concept,
you've been throwing it in front of this congregation.
What?
What do you have written down?
Do you have any studies,
any,
anything with some veracity?
Yeah.
Would you look about him to take a step back and look at any level of religion?
You're like,
oh,
what?
This might be garbage or this is garbage,
garbage,
garbage.
This is a bunch of people that we're trying to figure out what the fuck the
stars were.
No,
it was dark,
but it was great too long ago.
Cool.
I have a job with the 10 commandments and my new special paid regular fee.
You out this Friday night.
It's set.
Your DVR is funny.
Don't forget a lie to the bureau's cover central Malawi.
She feels
he's got to do special songs about.
I like,
and it's funny
and it's funny,
this Friday night,
is it censored or uncensored censored?
Online,
I mean on TV,
uncensored.
Online.
Uh,
so on.
If you have it on television that comes on after midnight,
they can do whatever they want.
Right?
They can have it.
There's stuff I'm able to get where they were like,
well,
we don't know about that.
I was like,
are you serious?
And I'm like,
oh actually it's after midnight oil.
Just fucking,
that's fine.
After midnight is the right spot.
Yeah,
I guess all except you want more people to see it but more people can at all re
shelf.
Yeah.
Like how many special ed again?
Last Friday night did it.
Really?
Yes.
That's great.
So you've got a bunch of like publishing to feed more of a heads up so I could
have promoted it.
The feedback has all been good,
man.
It's,
I mean the,
the,
the matter,
the ratio to people that didn't like it versus liked it.
It was way higher than my last one.
So that means I'm on the right track.
So I just,
I,
I think that,
like right now it's such an exciting time for standup and I'm so excited about
doing new shit.
Like I've never,
I don't,
I don't think in all the years I've been doing comedy,
I've had more fun doing it,
doing new stuff.
Fuck,
I'm loving it.
It's not,
it's not like you're not trying to do,
well,
you're trying to kill it.
But just with newer,
it's like taking a smaller bat and still trying to hit a home run.
Yeah.
Well you gotta grow.
You gotta throw willow,
Bro.
She got to keep using fertilizer,
stata mulch pits on
compost gas comedy.
Get your compost game up kid.
It's just,
it's,
it's just,
uh,
it's an amazing time,
man.
I have so much fucking fun.
Yeah.
Especially at that show in Vegas.
God Damn.
That was fun.
That was cool.
The Phoenix show was really cool.
That was fun too.
Yeah.
That's Terry Fator theater is really good for it and they got that fucking,
when I tell you the word,
I was looking for it.
When I tell you the word I was looking for,
it's where clock toward.
I couldn't find that.
My brain wouldn't,
that I gotta Stop Smoking Weed and start reading.
Don't do it.
The Combo to one or the other.
I got,
I can't let this keep going down hill.
I can't remember.
I've got to start working now.
One right here.
I can't remember what the word is.
I've got to get you on it.
I need Lumosity.
I need you to do some kettle bells.
Yeah.
Brain smoking
in London for fucking
three days,
allegedly three days in London.
That was it.
And then right back to it.
Did you not know anybody there or something or is working to do this thing where
it's where I was working so I was like quickly like doing,
I didn't have time to like go out and try to find weed and then I just didn't
find it too much danger in another land.
Yeah.
I got scared and take any with me.
Good.
That's smart overseas.
I'm always like,
oh,
how'd you know?
Sure.
No,
yeah,
to take it with me.
But,
but um,
uh,
yeah,
I just didn't find that name then you know,
it's like what you said Celebrity Rehab,
it's the easiest fucking thing to come off if you don't have any like,
oh well yeah,
I sure would want some,
but I've been working so I haven't time to do it.
Well,
if you watch celebrity rehab,
you see Eric Roberts on it.
Roberts,
Eric Robertson,
everyone's shopping the shape and what's coming off.
Coke and meth like need to make it through and I will Robertson's drinking
coffee,
reading the New York Times,
coming down off of weed.
He had his fucking feet and slippers.
He was in a reading.
Everybody else had fucking crusty Mascara all over their face and tears.
Fucking sadness.
Yeah.
Bandaids over their major arteries and doctor fucking drew still won't say it's
different than those other things.
Come on,
drew,
do you?
You do know people that can't stop.
Yeah,
I know.
but I know people can't stop doing a lot of share.
Yeah,
I know people can't stop.
Tattoos can't stop gambling,
right?
Yeah.
Wow Man.
We need glasses.
The Flyer looks really kind of weird.
Looks Mansion.
I wonder if like,
if we keep the,
Oh my God,
when we take them off,
it's gonna fuck a regular.
It probably was already fun.
I go over the blue,
it just goes off.
I go to my left side.
The plane just goes off gay gays into the burning magic.
You went to see this whole table.
We'll table projection.
No,
I don't want to see that shit.
It's cool,
man.
I've never seen Joe react so horribly done.
Intimacies of technology added new layers to games.
It doesn't.
A real pool table is played with fucking traditional lights and regular balls.
You keep everything clear.
This is ames,
Mr No bar,
no table to table bowling alley.
I'll see the bottom way.
Still felt but see through phones and no fucking
whole time.
Yes.
No.
Maybe you could play TV so you can watch the big game while you're lining it up.
You hate money.
Go ahead.
If you want to win,
you can't play like that.
A pool table supposed to be a green landscape of opportunity of collisions,
of maneuvering,
of English and spin and reaction to choc and balls colliding.
Slide and follow and draw.
That's what supposed to be not pussy and glass.
That's supposed to be looking down at a fucking glass table.
That's horse shit.
Now that that,
oh no,
no,
no.
It's not what it's about.
Get your own.
Make your own new game.
Okay.
How about you?
Just what I'm saying is he on a table?
Because my last tape,
their chest to instead of having straight up and down and so they would have the
go like this like lines.
You couldn't really see where another opponent was really couldn't really
visualize it.
Yeah.
Like you'd have the corner ones.
What's go?
What's your goal with the alcohol battle chess.
Oh,
uh,
rooks maybe bishop bishop is yes,
and they'd be like almost right above you.
So like,
well they can't get me.
But then you look at the way it's like curved and be like,
oh,
it's right in the dark is the castle right?
Rook is the horse.
Yeah.
No,
no.
The castles.
The rookie,
right?
Yeah.
The night.
What night is the horse night isn't worse.
I have wow.
For a game of,
for intelligent people,
we couldn't even remember the last time you ever even tried to play around with
it on my phone.
Like maybe a decade ago.
That was it.
What did you guys like?
Chinese checkers?
I was always a Chinese checkers.
No,
that was always my favorite things.
You could play up to like I think five people or something.
Oh yeah.
All marble.
There's a Jewish star square park.
You ever go there and watch shows?
Chess players,
they hit the clock and they slap the clock.
They only get so much time.
That's amazing stuff because they're really thinking about this grand plan on
this board and where all these pieces have opportunities and creative and
they're doing it on a clock.
God,
I'm dumb.
Ah,
I feel so stupid.
And they're like homeless people too that are playing in there.
Well winters,
the thing about pool and the thing about chess and thinking about this,
a lot of these games that are stroke grossing,
you get so locked like sucked into them that it takes over all your older ideas.
Like there's a lot of bachelors,
some bachelor in some shitty apartment and you don't,
you just give up on having a girlfriend and he just gamble all the time and he
gets sucked into that lifestyle and you see that a lot of times with like pool,
you see that a lot.
And so the pool hall Groupie,
like describe her when she gets passed around.
This is a groupie like three.
If you can think of anything.
If you could think of like a miniature golf,
there's probably a miniature goal.
It's Tommy dilutes showed me who the Po,
the bowling groupies was were right after I would send the UFC groupies.
That's when I realized everybody's got a group here are definitely pool hall
groupies.
They looks interesting.
They will go for the best players.
They always want to date the best players.
Not about looks or young.
No,
no.
There's like dudes who aren't that good looking,
but they're really good players and they'll get like pretty good lucking pool
groupies because the pool player girl like really wants to be associated with
like a world class player.
Oh yeah.
Or they pull players too sometimes.
Yeah.
Most of the time.
Most of the time,
yes.
Usually the ones who are like plague or pool players as well.
Then they really appreciate how good a guy is.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So there's like this,
but this,
I think that's the way with everything,
the cello players and fucking,
you know what mean in male to female as well.
I think there's men that are just obsessed with the way a woman's sings.
They become,
you know,
fan of that.
It just no getting around it,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
We're impressed by shit.
You just stay in that world and like it's all I all I care about to then that's
sweet.
Of course.
That's what you want to fuck.
If the guy's a bad ass pool player and that's all you care about is pool and
that guy's doing magic up there.
I was talking about David Letterman.
It's like,
well the problem was he used his power to to get laid.
You're like,
oh,
you mean you can't build up a bunch of power than use it?
What do you mean half the reason the bill power to become the president?
So girls would want to fuck.
He was like saying,
I won't keep you this,
this promotion without you fucking,
it's they're saying they just come in wanting to fuck because I'm president,
Bill Clinton and I supposed to suddenly he's go,
no,
that's wrong for me to accept.
And you're also supposed to deny a fucking Mongolian generations of conquerors
in there whore mongering way.
And you've used serp them to become the fucking king of the world.
I mean that you're trying to play the part once is the king of the world too
good.
I don't get late because of this system of all his nose in our country.
Fucking 200 years ago he's a no bull was Melbourne Cif here.
Nobody's at noble.
Even the fun horse.
He'd be game of Thrones.
No.
Well,
the game of Thrones is like really even the good guy,
he fucking cheated on his,
on his wife.
That's why I had that faster Sud that they sent to the fucking castle because he
cheated on his wife.
Right?
That's right.
That's a good,
that's the best man that's ever been in that fucking world.
That's true.
And He,
spoiler alert,
let's not say anymore.
She's not the rare,
stop it right there.
You know this is episode 600.
Yes,
that's crazy.
Episode 600.
I just did it as a 200 this week.
I'm skeptic.
Is that the same thing?
800 episodes between us?
That's what I'm fucking talking.
Yeah.
Shocking him out.
Jesus ain't,
have you done anything interesting on your podcasts lately?
Like top because,
uh,
you've,
my favorite one was the one where you had a talk with a hooker back in the day.
I've had a few good ones like that.
I had this guy who helps run work at the insight at that Vancouver placed with
safe shoot up place,
safe shoot up place hasting streets.
I'll fucking zombies and fucking heroin addicts.
And so they offered a safe shoot up place where you can tell them what you're
going to,
we're just going to shoot up on and if something goes wrong and they can tell
the paramedics how to have a broad view.
And so it's just not,
so it's not this dangerous and they give why the cops don't bug it.
And then,
wow,
they told me all about that.
What is like,
this is fucking going on.
And you know,
she's just regular questions.
It turns out there's no fucking going on.
It goes when you bought heroin,
that's sex drive goes way down.
That was a good one.
And then this week's about the open mic at the comedy store and that was a
really good one.
The open mic,
you know,
potluck.
Wow.
Talking about how it pretty much got it chopped in half and how it's not as,
no,
this was about the heyday with the,
with the,
it was the freak show.
But the when,
when you hosted it,
when it was just a freak show.
I'm giving up on his glasses.
Yeah.
I mean having an aneurism.
Let's do them backwards for oh to see what the authors are
different color a little bit.
Yeah.
Wow.
So much better.
Oh it is.
It definitely don't wear this for an hour or more.
Just kind of look at the shirt at him.
We did like almost two hours to those stupid fucking just got to look at the
shirts like wow,
cool.
And then take them off.
So when I hosted it was like,
um,
yeah,
I mean you host the employees and the showcases,
but before that part is the potluck part.
Where's the fucking 20 pure open micros,
which could be the guys like me when I started or can be fucking sky was like
boom,
Shaka Laka.
When did I host it?
If just that one time I almost regular open mic night.
I hosted people like going on for the very first time.
Yeah,
that's a Bob check did for years.
That's what I did for years.
Oh shack is a funny fucking dude.
I'm,
I'm just always amazed at Bob.
Oh Shaq didn't become like some sort of levy came.
One of the head writers that I'm at,
I'm forgetting,
but I would,
I have thought that he would be like a host,
a Letterman,
like a famous guy.
Like he's really funny and really nice.
I think that was a super nice,
really cute man.
Only fucked his wife ever one of those guys.
It was just like,
like,
like you know,
Polo shirt.
He's funny shit too,
man.
I think he really loves being in a fucking writers' room and just churn it out
jokes and I think he loves doing that.
Give me the topic.
I'll hit you with a fucking state hours worth right now.
I just,
I've always thought that guy was going to be like some big household name.
Like I remember watching him.
I'm like,
he's so composed.
He would have his bets.
He's like the opposite extreme of people who write on stage.
He wrote,
he was like 98% done with his bits when he brought him up for the first time.
I didn't wild.
Yeah,
he was the open my coast.
He was the potluck hosts when I started,
so he was like the first professional comedian and I saw over and over again,
powerful Babo shack bubbles out there representing Middle America.
Where's he from in La?
Some weird corn,
Tennessee or Alabama and those weird spots.
Oh yeah,
he wears it.
He wears it for sure.
It wears it like a shield,
like one of those motorcycle jackets that you would pants off.
She elbows.
It's going to be the best jokes.
Just talking about like it's okay to look.
That's all right.
But as long as you don't hop on her,
like she's the last chopper out or nom.
That's good.
Like lines.
He's a good writer.
Ren.
Yeah.
Funny Dude.
And just a good dude.
It comes around once in a while.
He's cool.
Does he still do stand up a little bit,
but Tommy would kind of was like,
hmm.
Kind of push them to the side.
So I think now he's back a little bit more.
That's really unfortunate.
Yeah.
Like I should get spots,
but that's uh,
you know when you're primarily focused on one club and you have a bad
relationship together,
that one club,
but it was time out with Mitzi too.
But to give him like one spot a week and it's like once a month and it's like,
why?
She just like didn't want any more,
I don't know.
But it,
same thing though.
It's one club.
You're talking about one guy letting you say yes or no.
Isn't there something when you see certain guys where you go,
okay,
I think if you don't really pay attention this guy,
you might see it one way,
but if you,
if you follow him long enough,
you realize it's like all these layers underneath there that you,
that you weren't even saying.
Yeah.
Like you're looking at him.
You might judge them.
Oh look at this guy.
He's wearing a tie.
He's on stage those glasses on and he's trying to be cutesy.
He's trying to be proper.
But then like you watch him a few times he'd go,
oh this guy is like really funny.
He's just making a presentation.
Yeah.
That's just how papa's you're like,
yeah,
why are you wearing a suit man?
Oh you're not a suit comic.
He doesn't wear this.
Yeah,
you're,
it's like we're being prejudice.
Yeah,
exactly.
Love it.
Cause he wants to look good.
We're like fuck you.
Where it's like if you like what on TV?
On some television show,
like the tonight show with Johnny Carson,
you had a Hoodie on
fucking wear something nice piece of shit.
You're not happy to be in front of us like it's your birthday there.
Some old jazz singer who got one trombone,
it's one of the greats like Dizzy Gillespie types and he was like,
the one thing I was told was,
I know it was living out of my car,
but they were like,
find yourself a good suit when you're on stage,
you gotta you gotta put all the most important when you don't have money.
That's why those nouveau reached Nirvana type motherfuckers had millions of
dollars nowhere until word added up to these honors all stars or to but one
button missing.
Like that was almost like a badge of courage that they like kept their wardrobe
as real as possible.
You know,
I get it.
If you do that at the MTV video music awards or whatever the fuck you,
you know,
you can do where every fuck you want.
When you're in Nirvana.
You don't have to wear suits.
Going to Kurt Cobain to wear a suit.
If Kurt Cobain went on stage with a Sudan,
that would be him fucking with you.
Like what are you trying to say?
Yeah.
The first time that night he'd be like,
ah,
I don't get it.
Why they were in a suit like,
oh that's Kurt Cobain wearing a suit.
Yeah.
Like yeah,
you're right.
Sometimes people just don't see it right away.
Like I wish you could see or comics sometimes choke under showcased situation.
That's definitely true.
I've done it too.
That's done on the auditions.
I've done it on an important sets.
Even your average is better than that.
It's hard to him.
I said like 20th percentile instead of,
yeah you could.
I mean up till the time you record a special,
like when you're,
you're trying to develop new material,
there's always the possibility that I could go wrong.
There's always that possibility.
That's all.
Dave Smith is comic Con New York.
Cause they were like actually a really good political comic.
But he's no,
when he went up with the seller and it would just fucking show and thought that
he had a way to route for her to come tell him no,
but maybe because we're always hold off in the back of your head like,
but maybe,
maybe she'll be like,
well that was good.
You'd have a good setup.
And I like it.
No,
just goes,
yeah.
Obviously I didn't do it right.
And also the Lariat,
I wasn't there so many times.
I felt so bad for him.
I was like,
I've been there waiting.
Maybe.
Maybe she'll just,
she'll,
ah,
no,
but they won't.
There's nothing crazier than watching someone perform in front of Mitzi and here
go,
he's terrible.
Ah,
have this day.
Gosh.
Brutal.
Nall piss my dream packs.
Give the back hand wave away.
You have dealings with her at all?
Yeah,
a lot.
Yeah.
In the 90s she was lucid.
She was a,
when I first met her,
she was,
I had many conversations with her about comedy and what I was doing wrong.
You say what she did wrong.
Yeah.
She was going to point out.
She goes,
you don't do no stuff in the beginning.
Yeah.
Barry at the mad cow.
Yup.
No,
she's right about that.
She was always really smart about challenging you.
So she would give you these sets where uh,
you would go on after I started killer her,
whoever she thought I was going to do the best she would shove you right
afterwards to teach you like collect.
This is what it feels like to be nobody.
Oh,
you think you're good.
You're good to go off to this Guy Martin Lawrence in 19 nine is five good
fucking luck.
Yes,
soldier God,
that would have been such a hard spot.
I took those spots there.
Martin Lawrence.
I had many of those spots in the main room and killer too.
He wasn't just famous.
He was eight hiller plates of dry bum shot
waiting for the light to come on please.
I bomb going on after that guy.
Here's when you know you're bombing in that room because it's so quiet.
When the neon light goes on,
you hear
and you're like,
I don't even have to look over.
I know I'm done.
Warm.
Your skin gets empty.
It was a change in your forehead
to Sanchez.
Said it.
Cause she made a phone with the ice every night.
Then he said he tried to be like extra dirty and that didn't work and they tried
to be extra clean that didn't work.
And then he was like,
well let me just
do what I do I guess.
And that was like what worked well was doing,
just trying to be funny.
You just have to accept your fate to the very least.
You got to prepare to dig your way out of the ditch in front of you.
Just keep hammering away at it.
Don't lose your composure and don't,
don't try to,
you just got to submit to the fact that you'll never be better than Martin
Lawrence and right.
Yeah,
exactly.
Cause there were good relaxed,
you're not going to kill the Jaycees those as good opportunities because like
the crowds in an awesome mood.
Yeah,
just kind of that's true.
And then some of it's being a comic and having to be like,
it's not just my material.
I gotta fucking move and shift with the fucking new room.
Well,
it's awesome.
Big J in 2015 is way better than I was.
Right,
right,
right.
I saw some most dogs
and he did this whole thing where it's like you got,
cause it was just like,
you know those are big moments for a comedy.
Right.
And he's like,
you guys just got Louis Ck.
You did.
That's not fun.
You can come in here thinking you were going to see him fucking 1145 at night.
You saw that and was like,
yeah,
they're getting now he's pulled him into his own wave wavelength with like 40
seconds of that and any mouth fucks mall and that he mouth fucks all above his
roars and how you're going to listen to my stories of childhood.
I liked me and he fucking killed.
But it's that technique of being able to like,
let me pull them in here.
Like being a legit comic.
Steve Simone is easily in the top 100 and nicest people ever to end to show
business easily.
If ever.
People that have ever lived,
he's easily in the top 100 nicest.
Oh yeah guys.
So Nice.
He's such a friendly guy.
Like,
who the fuck doesn't like Steve Simone?
Finally like Bruce?
Tell me you don't.
I'd never really experienced it.
I've never,
if you tell me you don't though,
then it's like something's wrong with you.
Come on my Carmichael,
draw a crime.
Say No to rods.
The second nicest guy you'll ever meet.
He's
just start a war between those two.
Really Nice guys.
It's a mode of her draw.
It's like a shit about you.
Let's bring in the pope.
Try it.
They'll do up this new pope.
Umea you might think he's pretty cool,
but here's what he said about Gerard Carmichael.
It's hugs or fake motherfucker that he's got enough strength behind them.
Sits in that regular chair and as soon as the camera's goes off,
bring me my 12
he's my example.
Somewhat of like a nice way to be.
Go out of your way to lock your door when he gets out of your car.
Well,
it's just,
he's one of those guys that you see me always want to hug him.
Yeah,
he's just a genuine sweetheart.
Here's a podcast house.
Good Times with Steve Simone and especial cds just came into the,
Ooh,
remember the
funny guy and the guy also homegrown,
homegrown comedy store veteran.
That's,
yeah,
it was teach Simone started there.
Started it might've done a few sets out to get out of that.
You would fill in and came,
but like only a few.
Yeah,
not much.
He grew up in front of us.
You know,
he was the manager that he worked there.
Bunch to work there.
Yeah,
I'll put up vomit.
Oh,
he's a good dude.
Always a good dude.
No matter what was going on.
Even a waste.
Suicidally depressed.
It was just nice to everyone.
Well,
you know when things weren't going as well as they are right now,
now he's doing great.
Like Steve Simone is starting to build momentum.
You know,
I hear a lot of people talking about him.
I hear tweets like when he was a,
um,
releasing his album,
we all retweeted his album and he,
people were talking about a funny is this is a very,
a very loved guy.
Now,
you know,
it's hard to get that connection.
And he's like,
the stories he tells on stage are so good.
Like he's like one of those guys,
a storyteller,
grads are like the best around at it.
I'm like,
fuck,
well he's just a lovable dude.
Charismatic level dude.
Yeah.
He didn't go to that style out of that battle like battle field of the company
is doing where he's like,
I'm going to be my thing.
I'm going to tell stories of childhood and fun times and beautiful things and I
can go out to some guy who was talking about going down in a girl during her
period,
like AAA and just fucking,
you know,
battling,
get some heckler and then he's going to be like,
well,
now we're going to reset and have a great time.
And it's so funny.
Ab.
Yeah,
but that's like also Sebastian Sebastian,
another one.
He's clean dice.
Yeah.
I mean it's bashing.
It's like,
but he's hilarious.
Drake killer and his own super clean way.
Yup.
And just like tearing apart like God,
you know,
messy.
We just talked about that.
He thought he was shitting on that.
It's like he's against that too.
What was it?
What was the topic with the topic?
I forgot what it was.
Uber.
Uber
with Yelp.
That's what he said.
When a teacher with your phone,
it's on everything.
It's a best God.
He's good.
Yeah.
I think that's what he said.
Is Hiv hiking with your phone.
Yeah.
He's funny dude.
I was alone in a hotel room and you saw the Sebastian special.
It's special on showtime.
I think I was Texas.
I think it was doing standup at Texas and just flipped on showtime and I watched
the whole thing and I was laughing.
I really,
really enjoyed it.
Like it was really fun.
He's great.
He's one of the best in the business.
Yeah.
It was cool to see though.
You know like cause again like to get past like Simone.
Yeah.
I saw a guy get that.
We're going to become a paid like a hole in the shell and got better.
Then be like,
okay,
you can stand on its own.
They start getting better and totally,
it was one of the best comics in the country.
Yeah,
yeah,
true.
That already.
That's just amazing.
I don't know who did digital.
I've got my wispy hair too and it's long.
That's how it gets.
I'll whispery like that.
Such a good photo with Bono.
Who drew it?
Oh,
who do that?
I remember that.
I don't know if somebody just posted on the message board and my long hair.
Why don't you uh,
asked whoever posted where they got it.
Let's see if we can give that person credit.
The whole thing.
That's amazing.
This looks like you fucked.
Danieli.
Bolelli.
Really?
He just fucked each other.
Other's my balls was my pillow right there at the hot bout half,
half Jew,
half Guinea kid.
That's pretty good that I'm tired from doing morning radio.
That's how my hair looks like that.
And there's your shower.
Let it air dry.
The morning radio thing when you're on the road.
That shit does get tires.
I'm doing it.
It's just cause you don't have a chance to sleep a full four.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like,
it's like you go to sleep,
it's like go to sleep.
Like I'm not tired of 10.
I was going to sleep at three 30 in the morning,
the last three straight weeks at 10:00 PM.
The guy from the message board actually drew it.
His name is,
uh,
Tom.
Uh,
so verb by put aside,
oh,
over by Thomas Thomas overbuy probably.
Oh,
there you go.
Tomas,
Tomas over by.
Wow.
He,
that's his own art.
Yeah.
Wow.
He did that while we're on the podcast.
He said that he started at the beginning of this podcast and know,
finish that right then it's probably been drawing as a child,
probably was vicious to me.
And then when they dedicated wall that's covered and yellow spackling saw the
dried come of as a Jack Hewlett rogue and he saw,
he was like drawing face.
He says,
he says,
I drew this last year from Ari,
seven minutes.
Shit sketch after failing horribly at a really drawing on us.
Yeah.
It comes from a 30 frame comic called Ra should fear Shit.
Anal Lube.
You Shit yourself and he fucks you.
It's a longer piece.
That's really,
it tells a lot about the world we live in.
It's changes,
it's meaning along the way.
Many times you got to stay along for the ride.
They get the full to get the full or just really,
really an aluminum me up.
Really just bathing me in it Kerry takes and that really shows how a mother and
child can really love each other.
There must be a guy out there somewhere.
I mean if you know you were talking about how you tore your penis because of a
lack of lubrication.
That's not a regular thing I've done by the way.
Okay.
It just happens.
It's not a big deal.
I understand.
I'm not judging you at all,
but would like someone with the diarrhea that would probably be way more
lubrication than normal and more lubrication.
Plus the whole area would be super relaxed and all blown out.
You just diet out,
empty out a fucking big gulp of splattery diarrhea at that little bottle.
It's like process like seeds go on the aside.
The ends of hot dogs to see him three times in Chinatown in San Francisco and I
was shitting out full noodles,
legit full Moodle's like everybody's like,
no,
we're not.
Dot leaves leaves.
I get at peppers but full noodles,
they were like the flake that my finger long one on my leave.
Your body's like,
I'm not buying it,
man.
I'm not fucking buy.
And they would call this food.
We do not call this food.
Why did they get it?
Like,
look,
I am running this through all my fucking natural computers.
It's coming up negative.
Did you,
is this gutter oil?
Good oil?
They have that and in China town,
I don't know.
Made its way.
I want to hear you hear the sound of it.
Plopping it.
You don't want to hear it man.
That the plopping sound.
I was like almost got you to a bar.
I believe Jamie is the second biggest fuck up.
We're not continuing to play that blowing.
Yeah,
it's dark,
dark world.
Yeah,
and that's happening right now.
Somewhere in the world.
Someone's digging into a sewer and pulling out a big shovel full of shit and
buying it at the store.
Just doing this.
It's cheaper than buying it at the store.
So we'd save money by doing this and look at the House that I bought.
If it wasn't for God a royal,
I couldn't have bought a house.
That lady built an empire on gun oil empire.
This lady's like,
she owns her house steep into that and the Republic of China.
Is that right?
Somewhere she thought,
well who knows what the fuck she actually said,
we're just reading what somebody translated.
Oh,
that's a great point.
Talking to English at all.
Yeah,
we translations are terrible.
Oh,
maybe they didn't say any of that.
She might've said I was about to lose my house and my children would have died
and everyone would starve to death and they had to take shit oil.
Oh,
eating it though.
People like a lot of people,
people I eat street food.
I didn't need street noodles though,
but eighth street,
new food,
but he's in an oil that they cook in.
Ah,
AH,
probably
eat street food.
The meat was great.
You would just point at a thing.
It would cause one yen,
which is about 16 cents and it was three or four pieces of a meat.
And I don't know how to pronounce any meat or how to say any of them.
So I'm like,
I guess that this one of those please two of these.
And if you ate it,
you didn't like it.
You just throw the thing out because it was 15 16 cents and the Ethan asks me
like,
this one tastes good.
What do you think it was?
Lamb,
chicken dogs,
male maybe.
Probably dog.
Great dog is more of a Korean thing they said is it said you could find it in
China,
but it's not like a really around much what the fuck.
But you know what I what it was maybe not one dog even more than I might've
wanted that before.
Just for the experience is you know how venison they got a clean,
well you probably know this has got to kill it clean.
Cause if it dumps the adrenaline going to kind of ruins the meat.
It doesn't hurt that.
Yeah,
it's kind of heard that as a theory I've heard is a theory,
but I don't think it's quick dog me.
This is the opposite.
They want the adrenaline.
So they beat on it for about two hours and smashed the cage and stuff.
No,
really?
Yeah.
And then kill it or tastier meeting.
I'm like,
well,
I'm out then.
Then I'm out and there's no way I'm only going to eat.
People meet.
I'm skipping over dog.
There's no fucking way.
Wow.
Can I only eat racists?
This was a pure bred racist.
This guy thought you're racist,
but some of these people were not.
I want a homophobe t-bone.
Yeah.
Really revenge or worthy cut.
What the fuck man?
What dog would you eat if you had to choose one?
I'd get retriever golden too.
Sweet.
Fluffy.
No.
Those fucking slobber dogs.
Get them out of the way.
Every restaurant,
another restaurant of fancy restaurant.
Someone brought in a fucking,
uh,
fancy festival shuttle support.
A big fucking Labrador retriever sat down next to them at a table while they're
eating.
You've,
you gotta be kidding me?
No,
it was clean dog.
Everybody brings in,
uh,
so restaurants.
We're not there.
We're not when motherfucking Marian haircut.
Dare you tell him,
Brian,
where are we from?
Where if I'm America,
We are America.
America.
We don't bring our dogs.
Sit down next to a brunch.
Yeah,
they probably wasted that meet in fucking oil shit oil.
You're,
you're still on that,
huh?
Dude,
I want to eat shit.
Well,
I want to,
I'll tell you something worse.
Whoa.
How's that possible?
I was on big Jay's podcasts.
Legion of skanks is kind of the
morning zoo type thing.
They have fun anyway.
They've been opened up fan mail because they're getting started as a podcast or
super excited,
but the fan mail they got,
they open it up on the air and they read it and they get sent stuff.
One of the things that got sent was cookies,
sugar,
cookies.
We had all gotten high and I was like,
fuck it,
I can make that show cookie.
And then uh,
Jay was like,
oh,
maybe you shouldn't need,
I mean that was just from a fan.
I wouldn't necessarily eat.
I'm like,
what's it going to be fucking weed cookie,
all the better.
Let's do this.
And he's like,
no,
all wheat.
We do like long segments about like we've done long segments about like coming
on food.
Like we have like a whole fight about it a few weeks ago.
Like how you can come on food and,
and then like make people eat it.
And then as a podcast,
when were,
we're like,
oh yeah,
I definitely,
yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
It's
just a calm cookie.
That's not nice.
No,
it's not.
It was terrible.
I was getting more nauseous at went,
but I was like,
yeah,
whatever happened in there.
And the edit podcasts you do,
you have like contest once drunk around the back of bets.
Recently Josh Martin lost and you guys all had to come on a towel and he had to
wash his face with this task.
The same guy.
You half,
half,
half monkey restaurant.
Joe Rogan Guy.
The same guy.
Yeah.
Tomas overbuy.
Overbay dude,
he's amazing artist.
Yeah,
Dude.
Yeah.
The bag of Beth's was of Sam.
Shelby came in the last two or as a fantasy league.
And not only do you not come in the final two,
he won the fantasy league,
so the loser has to take,
uh,
we all have to Tj's onto a rag and then they have to use that as their morning.
They have to re applied some moisture to reactivate.
Oh my God,
mark and wipe their face with it.
So were you allowed to wipe it off after you wipe your face?
Well yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But you got to wipe,
you can wipe it off.
You got to do a little bit of wiping and then you could wipe it off afterwards.
Yeah.
And how many days?
What do you mean how many days?
How many days you have to do this?
Just once.
Just to do it once but reapplied the Wa it's as if you know at the airport,
at the planes like fresh towel and you're like,
oh we'd love that.
I'd love that.
And then it really get it in there.
Yet the peoples come,
three peoples come three people's kind of cocky on the rag bag of bets.
I'm more sad to three people can come on a rag that easy.
It's that easy.
What is your kind of separate it?
We're not going to stand around it.
The third guy,
the third guy to come has a real issue.
The fact that he gets still shoot a load on the dying loads of his two friends
who are,
who are you and what's getting you off like,
Eh,
eh?
How?
How much does he knuckling his asshole
thumb deepened his ass?
I'm going to get their vigorously moving it.
Just shaking it as fast
as Josh already done this,
that we're doing the awards ceremony,
the comedy store patio.
He's got to do it there in front of everybody.
Oh,
we have all
these backup bets.
They're great.
They watch porn while they jerked off onto this thing or did you just jerk off
from it?
Just jerk off.
We just,
wherever we want to do,
it's up to us.
Here's the rack.
Now you go.
We had this bet where me and Tebow bed on a round of golf.
He was positive he could beat me and we put in there at loser has to watch every
episode of Whitney
in a row.
Write a book,
report about it in a raw.
Yeah,
I have to do what?
[inaudible] boy,
you have one day off in between seasons.
Oh,
Cuba.
I didn't get it right.
Yeah.
To Whitney Cummings has is fine.
I don't want to tell you what the bid is about.
I want to give up any of it,
but it was a murderous bit really.
She's got this bid that I've watched grow over like the last like three or four
weeks.
It's murderous,
dude.
She's been doing a lot of standup.
It's really interesting to see someone just really like catch momentum really
just like you see a bit and if she keeps working there no reason why she can't
pick him up.
Really,
really like great comic.
Yeah,
no doubt.
I mean you get the opportunity.
All of these people that get the opportunity like we'll get you up.
They usually just stop doing comedy.
Yeah,
no,
she does a lot.
She's always on stair,
on stage at the store.
I followed the store like three or four times in a row.
I've seen what the Improv all the time that check puts in work.
I respect the shit out of her.
She is always doing standup and she's always like tweaking stuff and adding this
stuff and changing stuff.
She takes chances.
She writes a lot.
She moves forward.
It's the Whitney model.
I tell everybody about who forward you go do something.
Well this podcast might just do it anyway,
then it won't go anywhere to do it.
What do you do?
Lost nothing.
The time you are doing nothing.
Move forward.
Yeah,
right a bit.
She's makes a short sketch.
Do something.
Just go,
she's a super likable person too,
like in real life and he talked to her.
She's really friendly,
you know,
so it's like you want her to,
you want her to be really good,
you know,
and that she's like,
she's,
I'll tell you off the air what this bit is cause I don't want to give up what
the topic of the bit.
It's God damn.
It's hilarious.
It's just funny man.
This is a good time,
dude.
I've been seeing so many funny guys that I didn't even know were around at the
store recently.
I got to start remembering people's names.
Santina know Theo Vaughn is really funny,
but you know what's the pasta?
This is the hidden Joran is the hidden gem of the game.
Man Wars gray going to bluff.
This is the history of the comedy store.
It's the late nights sets with either Brian Holtzman or Brody Stevens.
I have seen them for the past couple weeks.
I've stuck around and the last guy on stage in the main room does it as long as
they want and a lot of times they go on stage somewhere before 1:00 AM and they
have an hour if they want to.
They can go all the way to 2:00 AM.
It was anywhere between 60 and four people in the room,
so the show starts out,
there's 300 plus people,
places mobbed.
Everybody goes up crystally it kills bump it up and then it gets to the end and
then Brody Stevens goes up and Brody Stevens made,
I was fucking,
I was hyperventilating,
crying,
laughing,
and slapping the table,
watching you don't laugh.
I push,
I push.
You know who I am.
I push to those late.
Where'd you go to school?
He'll tell you.
They'll tell you where he went to school,
anywhere in southern California,
anywhere.
He will tell you a major league baseball player who went there and they go,
I know him.
You're going to treat me like that.
I went to,
I'm friends with your bureau.
Highest honored person.
Arizona state alumni.
Two and one.
I always like shit on us up a little bit at the end.
Joe,
can you picture joked during the big game on lemme make golf.
It fucks with my body temperature.
So lofting 40 for me.
I had to move on.
I'd like to get off the meds.
He's fucking awesome.
His late night show the other night,
it was not this past Friday night,
but the one before Mike.
God Man,
I was in awe.
He's well,
he's been doing so many warm ups,
you know,
he does warm up so much.
He's constantly used to just completely ad living in front of like this group of
people that's waiting for a television show to be for.
So there's like,
they'll fail my sag bad.
They'll,
they'll,
all right audience has to clap now.
And in between that,
what is setting things up a lot of shows.
I got there early and watch him.
It was like,
I just want to see you bro.
You're fantastic at it.
But when when he's so fantastic at,
and one of the things he does is he has this incredible ability to make comedy
out of it.
Nothing.
Anything that's going on like he's completely free.
Like he,
his,
his ability to ad Lib is like no ones like his ability to like move into the
crowd and just start bringing everybody together and polling like little,
little things that he said to this person,
to that person.
Like he's so used to being free when he's doing those,
those warm up things like constantly on,
just for free flowing back and forth.
Stayed at gathering people.
We're working here,
we're pushing it.
I push,
I'm from the valley.
Okay,
eight one eight till I die,
you know?
But he can do that in that rhythm with that sort of,
he's good.
He's in Jujitsu.
Wrong guys are the Rah Rah Rah or they just can't do,
can't do the warmup did.
He's a monster.
He was murdering the other night.
I mean fucking murder.
This is something that Eddie found the other day.
Eddie,
if this is what Brody used to send out to managers and comedy clubs and stuff
like that,
and it's a VHS tape,
the human 27 years of experience.
Trust me,
I understand comedy,
your friend,
the picture.
He's so awesome.
I'm such a huge Brody fan.
Yeah,
that's fun.
Especially when you're stoned and then you just like go in there and just laugh
and the crowds like half full,
so it's like,
oh,
this is great.
Yeah,
Holtzman almost how me Barf once I was laughing so hard,
I was almost like,
it was like the only that Jack outs to where I was like,
ha ha,
just couldn't barely hold it.
Those two guys,
if you ever see them on the lineup at the comedy store,
please go for the late night aspect to that.
I mean go for the whole show,
but stick around to the end.
Here's where,
here's where the story gets cool.
It's actually when you're out,
you're done out,
you're finished,
you're drunk,
midnight.
Should we go home?
It's like no midnights too.
It's just kind of raw jazzy environment.
The store.
So just heading to the store and sober up there.
The almost probably let you in for free.
Almost always,
unless it's still packed on a weekend or something.
Last night there was $1 million car there.
Right?
Parked.
Yeah.
Porsche fucking testers.
Porsche nine 18 they were testing it.
It felt like a man for sure.
Guys with Porsche jackets and there was a car ahead of them.
Two of the Porsche has a nice Porsche.
Yeah.
Oh,
I wonder if they like work.
I think it was a prototype.
Well No,
it's,
it's a cards available.
It's called a nine 18 it's this incredible car,
that $875,000 sticker value.
Yeah.
And that's if you can get one they're all spoken for.
So you'd have to pay some sober.
A male.
Yeah.
It probably have to pay over a million dollars.
Wow.
And it'd be worth it to like parked at a meter on sunset.
That's incredible.
That's $1 million.
I touched it while people are texting with my shit,
right?
Yeah.
People are texting and barely paying attention.
All right now.
And this car is parked on the side right there.
I was there that someone's like,
Hey,
look at that car.
We're like,
oh yeah.
Well I saw a VA run once in Hollywood,
which is even more expensive.
A big Gotti.
We've got Eva Braun Real,
I just want to be one of the fastest cars in the world is big giant spaceship
looking thing and that's more than a million.
Wow.
It's like a million and a half or something crazy there.
It is.
He only thing is like when they opened the doors I was really expecting door
thing that we like,
like go back and then up or something.
Babies just like this little regular door today.
What Porsche is like?
They're the best.
They're the best designers in terms of like the right compromise between like
ridiculous speed and power and handling and also like efficiency.
It's a hybrid car.
Yeah.
But it's also just the way they,
they don't make things that are too extravagant.
They don't make like from their Lamborghini coon Tashas,
you know,
they're like this big ridiculous fibery than cars.
Like they,
if they make a car,
like the width,
it all,
it's all about the engineering of the car.
It's like how fast can we get this car?
Like what is the best way to the road if they're making something like this.
But it's interesting because they're stuck with this nine 11 and that's the,
the,
the car that has the engine in the back.
It's like really not the best way to do it.
Like you're not really supposed to have an engine in the back.
It's like it's,
it becomes unbalanced.
It swings back and forth to widely guys because they started out doing it that
way back when they didn't know any better than that 11 yeah.
And then they've sort of stuck with it because it's kind of like a
characteristic of the nine 11
is this the kind of card that Paul Walker died in like this kind of like here's
was no more horsepower,
but his was a Carrera and the issue with Paul Walker's car,
everybody's like,
well,
the car was like really dangerous.
Like no,
it was not that dangerous.
According to everybody that I've talked to.
That's a car expert and is not coming from me.
This is Chris Harris told me,
Matt Farah told me the real issue was that the car itself had been on the same
tires for a long time,
like seven,
eight years and then they go,
they get hard and they have no grip and you have an amazing horsepower and
you're treating the car is if it's like a car with like current tires,
car tires actually harden and dry up.
Oh seniors in here.
When you're saying that though,
you sound like the guys who were defending pitbulls and like the 80s it's not,
but it's
no like high horsepower cars.
Like it's a really high horsepower car.
Yeah,
but it's not so high horsepower that it'd be dangerous.
Right.
You know like I drove a car,
it was dangerous.
I just heard it just was going on with you about and cracker and it's hard to
drive keep people who have crashed it.
What's a mid engine car?
It's,
it's,
it's got a really good balance but it's really powerful race car driver and so
fast and it doesn't have the same sort of like traction based technology that
they have in in 2015.
We have these weird like traction control like computers built in.
They know in one tire is like losing traction to compensate with the other side.
They break on one side to keep things moving at his old phone.
I know.
It's amazing.
You don't even have Bluetooth in your car and I just signed up.
This has Bluetooth.
I don't have a car.
Are you should fear for folks who don't know what we're talking about has gone
completely back to the flip phone.
I like it.
Pros and cons.
Okay.
The pros,
pros,
they're few and far between.
Uh,
one pro is I have to uh,
charge it every three and a half days.
Obviously.
The reason why is because you can't do anything worth trading it for,
but undeniable pro,
you don't have to charge it.
That's great
too.
You can do ignore without saying no on.
Somebody's remember that on no phones.
We could just stop the ringer without saying off the iPhone.
Never did.
Right.
They finally got that.
Oh yeah,
I've had it for awhile.
He just hit the volume button down or up and that'll just silence and then keep
bringing up.
You can't set it stop ringing but not,
yeah,
you can get,
go back to what you're doing.
You have to like wait for it to finish ringing right before you can go back to
your texts and shit.
Ah,
yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Like as far as declining it,
just way you want it and want to attend that.
You're not ignoring that call.
You just sit there,
stop pretending.
Stop pretending like I'm doing something I just said and I don't feel,
I know I do not get upset when people send me to voicemail.
Really?
You're like,
oh you were doing so please send me to voicemail for a goof.
I can't wait to send you to voicemail now,
but if you let me tell you this right now,
for every time you send me to voicemail,
send me another time to voicemail and avoid sending Joey Diaz to voicemail cause
he will burn your soul.
I can't talk right now.
I'm getting married.
I'll talk to you later.
Okay.
Bye.
Yeah,
you can't do that.
You gotta answer.
You got to talk to him now the now the cons,
they cock sock off voicemail,
right?
What are you been all day?
I don't know man.
It's been 30 minutes.
Relax.
11:00 AM has that camera.
That camera has to be amazing.
It's great man.
It's over one Mexico megapixel 1.3 I don't even use the camera.
And when I get text messages that have picture messages,
if it's any like look at this bed I made on a fight or something,
I have to forward that to my email and look at it on a computer cause I'm just
not,
I just can't see it.
Oh Shit.
And then you have to do it forwarding on your computer too from your phone,
your computer.
You have to do that all by pressing like individual buttons to t I need to hit
an s or to hit the number seven.
You've got to go 10 times because you're going to overpass the first time.
I forgot about that.
I think it doesn't get messages also cause I think I've sent you step up before
and you'd probably just never received.
Well you probably have that hair,
Sam shovel.
It just sent me up.
Just send me a picture.
Let's do you enjoy that?
That's access for the people listening.
It's about 40 pixels.
I don't even know what it is.
It's like a,
Oh my God.
No what it is.
That could be anything.
My God.
Is it like times square or is it a funeral?
Was He made sure?
Hey,
I only answer if landed now.
Ari,
is it annoying though?
Like if you're driving or like,
shit,
I'm fucking net after Ohio state won the game,
Josh Barnett at Ohio state with a game.
Maybe.
I don't know what,
but like if you're driving somewhere late at night,
you're lost.
God gone.
Okay.
Also.
So,
yeah,
can't no GPS.
That's terrible.
But I already have found two new train routes that I didn't really know it would
work perfectly for the in the,
in the six days I was off at in New York I was like,
oh the six train goes between here and here.
I don't like to just take this.
You know they have the APP that tells you that on Google tells you what it tells
you.
But it never tells me that the second drain and it's right there,
it shows you.
It didn't tell me that I've been there for a while and it would never show me
that.
And I'm like,
oh I can take this.
I don't understand.
Oh this one can.
I can like understand the map better cause you have to look and see what
connects to what.
So when you missed your train,
if you stop and tie your shoes and missed the one train and you can't get a
signal underground instead of being fucked like what's drink,
I took it like,
oh well any of these are the end,
the queue.
These all go there and you can figure it out by learning the maps,
which you don't do when you have it on your phone at all times.
Sound recorder for you know,
existing.
Nope.
I have to open it up.
Keep it in my pocket open because we've closed it has done.
So you're going to go back to,
and you're gonna get an iPhone six tonight.
Gold one.
No,
I'm not.
I'm,
I'm way more present.
I'm more social instantly.
I look at my surroundings more.
That part is all carried on forward.
Carry forward as is and a,
trust me right now is the worst time for me to do this.
Why is that?
Because I've got a special,
I'm trying to promote coming up Friday,
Tom RingCentral at midnight.
I've got my storytellers,
when you call it coming out a week from Thursday,
that's starting.
Why don't you make a statement out there to all the techno files and perhaps
tech note junkies,
shall we say?
Well,
I don't know.
People said they couldn't live without it,
but it's like this is what we lived at seven years ago.
You can't live without.
You can't possibly live without you,
but you'd live with seven years ago.
Like your life has been enriched by abandoning the smartphone.
Yeah,
a little bit.
Really.
Here's the deal.
We haven't tested it yet.
We haven't tested what the etiquette is.
The only reason people don't text while they drive anymore because they had to
make a law against it.
Otherwise people just would.
So the idea that everyone will control it the right amount of time.
It's sort of ridiculous.
They won't,
they've proven not to.
The,
the battery on the iPhone three was minuscule compared to what the iPhone six is
and it lasts the same amount of time cause we're on the phone way more.
I was going to say that you,
you should have like a phone,
like a regular phone and then an iPhone to do like social media type shit.
Yeah,
like an Ipod.
Then the problem is two hours in bed every morning before you get out of bed.
That's your issue.
Right.
Sucked into the,
you get sucked in and people say,
well just don't use it.
Well since five years come back to us.
We have apps.
I get it.
Yeah,
it's great.
It's,
they're great.
They're great.
I think too much.
I think for your [inaudible] you need it.
No,
you would just say you need I tweet from my phone.
I can Instagram from my computer.
You say you need it,
but do you need me?
You can Instagram from your computer.
I didn't know you could do that.
Oh that's interesting.
I want to use the web browser.
Then you can like change shit on computers and stuff you can't through like on
your phone and then like update it right there.
Put memes and yourself
Janky down.
Yeah.
No you would like that anyway,
but,
but like,
uh,
I just don't,
you just don't trust yourself.
And I was my seed on elevators.
The door's closed.
Everyone gets out like that and you don't,
people don't get to look at each other.
I walked on the street in New York,
I go 10 blocks and one of the most exciting cities in the world and I haven't
looked at my surroundings at all.
I just haven't even had any new input.
And you get connected with everyone.
There is that,
but you're connected really with the circle.
You're already in friendship wise,
so then you don't make new connections.
You're like,
yeah,
I can connect with this friend.
I'll tell him how he is on Facebook or on or whatever on text and then just no
reason.
Their body doesn't make you like say,
Oh hey,
you written that book.
I read that.
It's a good book.
Everyone just shuts in.
They just go to their phone,
kept bother somebody on the phone.
Similar.
Dana White's just going like right out Dana White,
this mean I knew a tail,
she was a flip phone and I was like,
well that makes sense.
But then Louie was like,
yeah,
I went to one or two.
I was like,
no way.
Really.
I mean,
you've got a lot of shit going on.
And then when I found out Dana white flip phone,
I found out Dana White did it too.
And I'm like,
God damn,
you know why has never moved from a flip phone?
Dana white is so good,
but his flip phone,
he could send you a message while looking right in your eyes.
He knows exactly what buttons to press.
He said all sorts of people are doing it.
I asked him about,
he said all sorts of people are doing it.
Wow.
That he's like more and more like,
like people that are like winning in life,
like doing shit.
This is how easily influenced I am.
I'm ready to switch.
I mean,
here's the deal.
This is growing pains,
those growing pains.
The first day you're like,
ah,
I need it,
but that's what happens when you quit caffeine.
You're fucking,
you got headaches.
Fascinating.
I think if you have an iPad mini,
it's totally do that.
The reason it seems like,
I think if you have a 42 inch screen,
it's on a wheel or
handlebars.
Why think nowadays great snapchat,
half of them is just to get laid.
Half those things are just like instruments of sex,
GPS,
the area.
It's true.
I mean the reason I have a Facebook fan page at all,
it's because some woman wrote me that once my on their Watson pretty much laid
it out there.
She wanted to hook up and I was like,
damn it,
and I missed it.
It's already gone from the city.
Then I check it every two days.
We won't go without checking it again because of that one time.
All right.
It's going to be okay anyway.
It's been pretty cool.
I'm okay with it.
She just sits wrong.
Weird.
Uber's tough.
You can only Uber away.
Can't over back.
So in a city like this where I don't have a car,
what I'll make them.
You can only take the bus for the first time.
Does that mean we're from my computer?
Oh.
And then getting back home,
it was difficult and you can't get back up to what?
From the,
where took the bus from the,
from the,
um,
from the doctor's office.
What the fuck are you saying to me?
You took all his clothes here.
I just looked,
I was like,
oh,
that goes right by the prevalence or regular bus in Los Angeles,
California.
I take it twice.
First of all,
the first time there was like domestic.
It's first time there was two black people.
There was a fucking,
a couple from Australia to white people and maybe like six or seven Mexicans.
But most of other people too,
and then the second time I took it,
they were full on homeless people on that.
It was pretty disgusting.
Tinder's probably impossible.
Tinder is being asked,
but it's hinder.
I'd delete it from my phone nine times anyway,
I've already taken I too much with world of Warcraft.
I'm like,
I can't anymore.
We're not getting nothing out of it.
I'll delete it and then like a month later I'm like,
Oh,
you just did the Tinder.
Don't do,
they don't have any apps that really limit your app use and don't do.
They don't know.
They have apps that tell you you're at your two hours and you're like,
ignore.
Keep going.
Well,
you can always shut it off.
All right.
[inaudible] your settings and say,
fuck you.
You could only double tap on that bottom button.
Delete those bitches,
but then you just read,
get them immediately maybe.
What do you mean?
That's so easy to do when you learn how to have a little discipline in your
life.
Absolutely are not.
Stop blaming it on an iPhone.
I got rid of cable for the same reason 10 years ago.
Again,
I'm not wrong.
Cable boy was no,
it's better for cable.
It's better to have cabled and did not have cable.
Okay?
You don't have to watch cable.
If you have cable.
I do have to constantly be glued to the fucking television.
God.
It's a sickness.
It's always on.
You can get away from Brian.
Come on.
Can't do that.
That's ruining Tinder.
Now girls don't see it as a real match.
We actually do math because you're a fucking idiot.
You're just like,
like liking all day.
It should be something special.
Then once you do like each other,
now they're like,
wow,
this guy's interested in me.
Now.
They don't even know that because your view guys that are always liking
everything,
you and Pete Davidson and all of these guys
like like like like a little class with it.
Nope,
it's a fuck site.
Just have a little bit of class if we can.
I'll have a nice fuck site.
You're ruining it with your fucking lack of patients.
Is he ruling it?
Talking about it right now.
Now it's a great site,
but is it part of the ground that's ruining and talking about it?
Is it ruining it and talking about it did way more damage than I did because he
just wiping night people that that benefit just excepting everybody is,
it's more a better odds.
What do you do when you're sticking it right in front of our face?
What are you talking about?
You were interrupting the conversation.
It's showing this all this.
Blame it on me.
I wouldn't even brought,
yeah,
I would dare you.
How dare you?
I love what you're going to hear.
A laugh.
And when someone knows they've been like,
oh yeah,
good point.
I kind of laugh.
It's like,
but my point was just trying to show you that you can't do Tinder.
Like how,
I mean there's,
there has to be so many things that you are action.
I'm so addicted to Tinder is one of the best examples of why I should not have a
phone.
It's garbage.
It's awful.
It takes all your time.
All right.
What if something crazy happens?
Like,
you know,
like terrorists.
Let's see,
let's talk about it.
And you are like,
you know walking in a park and you hear all these explosions,
people screaming,
you go to your phone and your what?
Your text based.
I don't know if was going to go to their phone.
Someone's going to be like,
it's the fucking terrorists.
They separate that way.
Okay,
you probably checked your phone rubbed that way you say,
fine,
I'm not going to wait and fucking it turns your mind so I fucking search engine
will.
You will be so easy.
Everybody does.
When they show brought their apps,
if I was like,
no,
let me do it on my app.
Let me get the Google search so easy to deceive.
I'll go down fast.
That's going to get the pull up the wrong website that just stick sticking in
your face.
It's going to be one of those like onion type website Snopes.
It
are running.
You're running.
There's no dragons.
Your bread.
He said this,
I'm going to pick us up in here.
They use your footage for the documentary of suckers.
Bridgend x files just on these are dummies without Google.
Watch what happens to them.
Keep Google in your life.
Okay.
If you're on the run a road trip,
you're on the road doing,
doing a Gig and you ran out.
Give me a better example.
Can be a better example.
And you rent a car with a gps in it.
Say it didn't have GPS and getting off.
I rent the car,
you get lost.
It's four in the morning.
You get completely lost your your car.
I'll do what I did in high school and I'll find my way home and it'd be such a
fun adventure.
That'd be such a fun adventure.
Trying to find your way home.
Oh,
we used to do it all the time.
I would just let myself get lost on purpose.
Oh God.
It was fun.
You're learning surroundings that way.
You really see a city that seems like a terrible suggestion.
Get lost on purpose.
When I was in Shanghai and I had the fucking gps telling me exactly which public
transportation directions to get there.
That's amazing.
That's awesome.
And I'll miss that.
I might get a gps.
How about you just have a little discipline here?
Fucking iPhone.
Texting sucks.
Your voice quality sucks.
But I'll tell you,
that's a shackle son.
That's technological shackle.
I'll tell you what I've found really interesting.
And also by the way,
you can watch my special on your iPhone.
So yeah,
you can watch on a flip phone.
No,
you cannot watch it off my phone.
Please watch it on my flip phone.
Um,
the reaction people give me,
to me it's like,
I'm just doing this for a while is really similar to the reaction of smokers
give when you say I'm quitting smoking a pill.
Poppers give,
when you say I'm done with pills or alcohol,
it's real similar.
People react sort of viscerally.
They
get angry at you here on that right now you are here like [inaudible] get mad.
[inaudible] you were all talking but like,
like what are you doing?
Stop that.
It's like,
why do you care so much?
People that have addictions,
like if you're a coffee drinker and you go to have coffee with your friends
every morning,
but if you did,
no,
I don't do that,
then they go.
No,
but I'm saying what I'm saying is if a guy just quit on you stop drinking coffee
and you meet every day,
like you're not going to have coffee.
No,
I don't want to.
I'm going to have a water.
Oh,
well you're too good for coffee.
Yeah,
exactly.
Come on.
Have a fucking coffee.
What are we doing?
And have a coffee,
but it was like,
come on,
you get rid of your iPhone,
dude.
We have iPhones.
We have iPhone doing cut.
Don't fuck this up.
I want to be able to Google.
I want to be just like you.
I love it.
I love Google and Uber back and forth,
back and forth.
It's like pros and cons.
It's really outweigh each other.
I don't,
I'm going to try it this way for a little bit.
Why don't you just trust just,
this is just,
why don't you just,
why don't you try this?
Why don't you try going back to iPhone like a fucking human.
Yeah,
and then this is the move.
This is the move.
Just write a rule,
a rule where you can't look at your phone.
I had one more.
I was like,
I won't even,
I won't check it until it go.
Just let me go to a coffee shop,
which is like a block away from me in New York.
How about we just go outside and then that can check it off from there.
You and I was like,
well let me check once before I go out.
Give yourself,
give yourself three points in the day where you're allowed to text message.
Are you going to check text messages?
Can I translate that for you?
Are you going to tell him that about cigarettes?
Um,
I'm not telling him about you.
Only you only get three cigarettes then.
That's a good way to do it.
You know a dog's ear right out of the litter box.
He's one of those.
And he yelled at him a couple of times and he keeps stopping fucking
torso deep into a litter box.
She went on cat shit.
Those dogs are always going to eat.
Catch it.
You know,
why didn't they like it?
You got to leave them alone.
Alright.
But a smoker you're going to tell them to like you smoke three a day,
but I can't tell him that.
No,
not that I can tell you that you're right,
but you wouldn't tell me to smoke three a day.
I would not tell you to stop any so stop cause that's going to give you cancer
but I don't think the cell phone is going to give you cancer.
Have you checked your test message?
Check your text messages three times a day but it won't just be that you're
right there.
If you only give yourself three strikes,
carry around a pack of cigarettes in your pocket and say don't smoke any.
Give yourself three strikes.
Always.
Did they have these programs that you can say it lights up so you've gone over
your hour.
I'm a man or that use.
I'm a man.
I don't even know fucking program.
You just tell yourself I don't.
I don't really think I need any of those things.
Besides text and email,
texting,
email,
text and phone.
Do you still have a copy serve email address?
My agents.
I tell them like,
if you need me something,
follow up with the only right away you're going to have to just call me or text
me and say,
Hey,
I sent you an email and check that.
Cause they business wise,
they always feel like that anyway.
Like how can even check the email?
Like,
I don't know.
It's been four hours.
Right.
They want you to be checking your email all day long.
You're in an office.
I'm not.
Yeah,
immediately.
And it's weird that they don't want to talk to you on phone.
Just call.
Yeah.
It's,
hey.
All right.
Listen,
you gotta listen to this.
He said new offer coming in.
They want you to shave your beard porn.
I get it,
man.
Yeah.
Porn.
I've got to drag my whole fucking laptop over my bed like a God damn fucking
bitch.
Oh,
can I asshole?
Why don't you do it that we had done?
You can't just fucking,
ah,
oh God.
It's awful.
He runs out of battery runs out
or Ari,
it's not like,
aw
damn.
It feels good to be a gangster.
Yeah.
Ari.
She fear given as little foxes possible slinging some 1996 technology out of
EBS.
I was like,
did you have a special at a show coming out?
Why do you have a flip phone?
It seems like that's not even the best one.
You can go.
I researched it.
It's pretty good.
Damn.
It feels good.
This one's one of the better ones.
300 contacts.
Yeah.
I didn't realize that would be an issue until it was like no fucking way.
Some of these are a hundred contacts.
Wow.
Yeah.
You're going to decide this one has 300 so that's good.
300 plus I think.
You know,
you've got to look at 300 dude.
It's like for phone calls for calling people pretty fucking dope.
Yeah.
You get you right up to your ear.
Does it doesn't have,
does it have Bluetooth?
It does sync up with a car.
Have you done that yet?
No,
but I could but I don't drive my Bluetooth it from the other phone.
Where do they fit it?
Between the battery and all the phone shit.
But when you think about it,
man,
like there's something satisfying about like going well,
looking at open know.
Oh yeah,
hang up.
Just like that.
We'll take that part.
Feels good.
That's a pro.
All right.
Take care of pro.
That's pretty darn sure you get a case that would do that.
They should have that for iPhone cases.
It's a slap shot and there's no like pocket calls or nobody's stupid shit.
There's no pocket texting or you open up and you're all fucking,
your phone's on.
Spotify has a lot of unexpected thing.
Oh yeah,
exactly.
It is that,
how did it do that?
People skyping me all of a sudden genx trying to make the call.
Thanks.
Yeah,
this is pretty dope,
dude.
I would have to have a phone too,
but I went and started doing way more sets in New York 23 or four night.
I would,
uh,
my body reacted weird after a while.
I was like,
oh,
I think there's too many spots.
Because I was like not really getting the most out of them.
And then I just overcame that like learning curve and I was like,
oh,
actually okay if I just gear up for it,
this is fine.
But it just felt too many because it was twice or three times as many I was
getting before,
you know?
But then it was like had to get used to it and now it's like,
cool,
I like that.
And now I've had one spot at night in New York.
It's like,
oh,
come on,
that's wasting it.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
So a lot of these low with his phone where it's like,
oh,
I got to have that.
It's like easy.
You'll get over it just like cigarette or just where it's like if you wait 10
minutes for smoking,
that's a good way to quit smoking.
If you wait 10 minutes every time you have an urge.
And then if you still have the urge to go for it,
get back to me is,
it's like promoting shows.
I even like,
Oh,
I need pretty much judge while I'm on the road,
you know?
I'm like,
I'm like going and get something to eat.
we gotta be better about doing that from my computer.
But you can time tweets out from hoot suite.
Really easy.
It's sometimes,
yeah,
sometimes.
Sure.
And then there's,
sometimes you write a whole bit because you're meeting someone and you're not in
your phone checking your fucking Instagram and you have a of all that meeting.
I mean,
you've said it,
you've seen all the people on stage doing jokes about apps.
It's nonstop because everybody's life.
I just,
I guess I use my phone for way more than just Twitter.
You also use it for way more than just work.
Yeah,
but I mean I'm using it as my voice recorder on stage.
I'm using for my g my ways on the way home here to just see which way I should
drive home some nights wasting an extra hour in traffic.
Right,
right,
right.
You know,
there's just so many like little things that like,
I mean,
do you eat 24 so when I get home there's going to be food waiting for me.
I can't,
you know,
there's so many little things that,
it's,
yeah,
but you don't have a problem with being addicted to your phone.
It doesn't freak you out.
I think what Ari's doing is
you're trying to optimize the way you think and you're trying to optimize where
you focus your attention on and you felt like you were spending too much time
just staring at a little device and it was taking away from the way you think,
taken away from the way you interact with people.
Just totally taken away from that way and interact with people.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Well just saying that,
you saying that and you know,
taking into consideration,
it made me reconsider it.
This is this etiquette.
It's evolving with it now where people are on it during dinner a lot,
you know?
And it's like,
well,
we don't know we were supposed to or not because it's such a fast changing thing
that we haven't built a fucking a way of a,
or a system around it.
So we're developing it now.
You know,
it's becoming more and more like put your phone away.
It's dinner time.
Right.
You know?
Right,
right.
But it's like we're going to develop,
we don't know.
It's just getting busier and busier and all the time and yeah,
it takes you away from who we were around because isn't that what it hipster
stays and that with the whole thing,
that hipster is what it's like against the,
you know,
that's not hipster yet is
hipster.
Right.
That's exactly the term of him against the norm.
When you think about,
goths also went about like all those groups are against like the norm.
Yeah.
Hips.
You're just one of those groups that's upstairs was just Uber fashionable.
Well they're just fighting against what they think is like a staid and boring
standard.
Yeah.
You know?
But yeah,
fighting against the currently accepted dress codes and all that shit.
Wear cardigans.
There's something to like,
you know how when you're on stage and you can't think of a joke and you're just
like doing it anyway,
but you need an ending and you just put the panic in your mind will force you to
create an ending.
Right.
Then at times,
yeah.
If you don't have your phone to go to when you're in an uncomfortable social
situation,
you'll feel that uncomfort,
um,
comfort level for awhile and then your body will like,
I don't like feeling this way,
so instead of going to my phone,
that was a way out.
Now it's like,
Oh hey,
you're a Raiders fan too.
Yeah,
I fucking man,
whatever.
They had some good years there,
whatever it is.
Just something to get out of this uncomfortable thing.
Can't just met somebody at home now with them trying to make a new friend and
they're on Uber all day and you're on Uber or Ram or storage place following all
these cars tweeting up a storm and Facebook and up the joint.
I could see he spoke offers nothing new your life anymore,
but it does.
If you like Facebook,
it's for some people Facebook is this like their community of Friends of friends
that you're like,
I don't even
know most of these people.
Most people don't know most of their Facebook friends.
Right.
I have no memory.
They have to really think hard and they're just an online community.
I Dunno.
It's okay.
When you go,
that part's cool.
But then you're missing other parts.
What do you think about the potential for virtual reality's online?
Have you ever talked to Duncan about this?
You know what I mean?
He showed me this oculus game.
Have you seen the new version of the old version?
I saw one from like a few months ago.
Yeah,
that's the,
I haven't seen the new one either,
but he called me at the Improv one night with fevered pitch in his voice.
Man,
it's out.
Game Changer,
man.
Dude,
this is fucking bigger than yet.
Annette,
this is bigger than space travel.
This is bigger than anything.
Told me about this a oculus rift where it,
it's this guy goes into this room and it's all in like four k HD and he said,
you really feel like you're in this room and you walk up to a piano when you
interact with this guy that's at the piano.
He's like,
it is a mind fuck.
He said,
it's so stunning and so realistic that you know,
it just makes you realize like,
oh my God,
this is like if,
if technology,
inevitably we all agree is going to continue to get better.
I mean we've all experienced nothing but that in our life and there's been some
bottlenecks along the way,
but people always figure out some new power source or some new battery supply or
soup.
People figure out how to get people unlike any of us in this room,
right.
They figured out how to get through that shit.
We assume that they're going to keep doing that and if they keep doing it,
if they're at that now in 2015 is insanely fucking rich,
high definition oculus rift where you're looking around,
it almost feels like you're in the room.
They apparently,
the way they filmed it,
they put cameras all over the guy.
So like everywhere you look like they have like an image for that.
Well you can look down,
you can look up,
you can look at the sky,
you could walk through the room and look behind you.
Like you,
you,
you're walking into it like it's a three dimensional environment and they're
going to be able to do that with these,
they have these like circular treadmills there.
3D treadmills.
So it's like the hollow hollow suite from a star wars.
Yes.
You just running around in these things.
You put the head gear on and you sort of like run around on this
multi-directional treadmill.
The treadmill goes left and right and back and forth and as you're moving around
on it,
like eventually you sort of get a groove with what you're seeing and your
headset and what you're feeling when you're running around and you're running
through this artificial world.
Wow,
this is going to get really intense man.
Yeah.
Then what are the longterm effects of that?
Like I'm short term.
It's like,
oh I dunno,
but like longterm it's something different too.
Like how does it feel once you would like the kids today?
Like your kids.
A lot of people get sick from it though.
That's it.
Oh yeah,
I was nauseous.
That's what they kept selling and stuff.
[inaudible] it's like,
yeah,
some,
some people have a really hard time with like cars.
Even with it,
you don't know which way it's going or you've looked down and it looks a little
bit less down than you're looking.
Yeah,
I have one and it kind of makes me after like a good three minutes,
I'm like,
all right,
I got it taken off the infringer eyeballs.
So if you look down,
then you're looking at there,
but then you look further down with your eyeballs,
you know,
but it just reads it.
Your head is going down.
Maybe because when I'm in the front seat on Laurel Canyon and not driving,
I don't know when it's going to turn right or left.
That's when I get the most nauseous.
What they're going to do eventually,
they're going to be able to three d map your body and you're going to be able to
just show up,
like kicking the door of an orgy and chicks are just going to hop onto your Dick
and you're going to feel it.
You're gonna feel them touching your body field and touch it.
You know,
go into this thing with electrodes placed various spots in your head.
I mean if you make it bond basically real,
perfectly real,
where did you,
your body can't tell the difference then QMAP and you're not really going to
have a reason to leave.
The only reason I leave and see the outside world because you can't replace for
Gout,
but if it's Kevin replace reality,
then it's like really?
There's no difference.
They there.
You would want to live in somewhere that we want to look ducks like Montana in
the winter just for like a day where it's really brutal.
You want to just to,
just to appreciate the reality difference between what this artificial world is
that you have in your little computer set up and what the real world is outside.
What if you get,
it's getting sun in the artificial world.
I'll bet you can I it fill your vitamin D sun while you're getting blown on the
beach.
One son,
you know you're at the mass of a boat or kings real draining on.
If you got it wrapped around your wrist several times,
you're holding onto the mass to being pulled across the ocean.
You can hurt all those things like that.
Well checks or blown.
Yeah.
Wow.
Come on.
That'd be great.
That's [inaudible].
Keep magnification.
If we really do come up with some sort of technology that it replicates that,
that'd be what,
what incentive to people have to engage regularly going to,
so let's just assume they're going to stop cause I don't see a reason why they
would.
That's carry as fuck to think that you could create an artificial world.
There'll be so intoxicating that people wouldn't want to participate in the
regular world were on that direction.
Now,
who as soon as this podcast ends you both,
all three of you and I would have to,
I'm going to bury yourself in your phone for the next 30 minutes.
Catch up in correct.
My willpower is outstanding.
You feel a nagging at you at all times to write.
I certainly do.
That's like a pull,
like,
Oh God,
I gotta stop.
I gotta check this.
I'm getting way better at it.
Getting way better,
like putting it down and just leaving it somewhere.
I'm developing a manner system about it,
but people get upset.
That's the other thing.
If you,
if someone texts you and they're like,
you know,
and they'll text you like three hours later or not like,
sorry,
I just got back to my phone.
Like I put it down for a while.
I don't want to be always available at all times and go see a movie.
People like don't even give you a raw.
I lock it in and just drop it on and I forget I even have it on.
You got to do that.
I think you've got to disconnect and I know you promote shows and you promote
shows and I promote shows and you know,
like you,
you can use that as an excuse,
but I think there's something very admirable about what you're doing.
I think there's a,
there's some wisdom in what you're doing too.
Well that's all I wanted.
Some goddamn respect.
I'm respecting it.
I think it's the move.
I think the two have both is the move.
But to give that to your closest friends,
I think that's the move.
So when you,
uh,
you have to do some horse shit,
you know,
you got to do some fucking tax problems.
You got to call on it too.
He had that guy sign this and specs that Monday locker on the phone,
all that shit on the phone.
Do that on the iPhone.
But all your friends,
your actual real social interactions,
if you put someone in your regular flip phone,
you really care about them.
You just keep this in your car just in case if you need to drive or go to see
what a good way that's just keep it in my car so I couldn't even use it,
my bed.
And you can keep that on you.
So just to make,
if you have to plug the battery into the,
into the thing and it's super glue that literally cannot unplug it from the car
charger ever again.
Yeah.
Why?
It's not going to have my car leave it in my car.
That's actually a good move.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I mean you could always break it loose and go some fucking asshole.
Super glued my charger to my phone.
Can you fix this?
They just get her a new one.
I guess that'd be too hard to get on right there and go on Twitter.
Apple Care,
they probably have a Kensington lock or a case that's a Kensington lock,
which is trying to lock.
It's just a case for an iPhone that you can just connect it to like a wire,
kind of what they use as displays at Alvarez.
Can't steal it or something like that.
Glues to it or something outside of it.
Yeah.
I guess if you,
they have them at best buy,
they would have to be able to sell them to regular people.
It's not like it's government secrets or some shit.
Yeah,
it was by one of those.
Yeah.
You probably could.
You just keep that shit in your phone,
your car,
or maybe in your house.
Great.
Let's go to an apple store after here and we'll get you an iPhone.
I need to get into this in the game.
I'm off the train you a little bit harder.
One Junkie,
just off the train.
Hard to track you at that phone.
And where are you at?
That's it.
Catch you on
like a track at my friends at all times.
That was one of the,
uh,
this,
there's several things stand out as being a ridiculous to call racist.
Uh,
one of them was Margaret show at the Golden Globes,
you know,
and with this thing,
Margaret showed the Golden Globes,
uh,
played,
came Giang loons publicist from North Korea or really put like white face on
like put on like,
like Pale makeup and like played the dictator,
a dictator or someone who works for the dictator.
Right.
And people were saying that it's racist.
I'm like,
dude,
she's fucking,
that's the race she is.
She said it's not racist.
It's racist.
I don't give a fuck.
She's great.
Well,
she's fucking Korean.
Not only that,
she's a mixed North Korean and South Korean.
Okay.
So fuck off man.
She can say whatever she wants.
Like it's just people are just waiting.
They are just sweaty.
Trigger finger say racist.
Here's the problem.
This is not just saying a racist thing is not racist acts or racist murdering
people because they're black.
That's racist.
Just saying,
I hate black people.
You haven't done anything to the world so fine.
So it's right as you haven't done anything,
go off to people who are actually doing something.
Yeah,
I guess,
but I mean that,
oh,
this guy has that opinion.
Okay,
so let him have that opinion.
Just ignore him.
That's him being as racist.
Sell
fine,
but you can't not hire black people at your company or we're going to run you
out of here.
That's the line doing something.
Yeah,
but you don't want a hostile work environment.
You don't want somebody going out to people and say,
fuck you chink.
You don't want that.
And obviously I chose Cenk because the other one's going to be too divisive than
other words.
The N one.
Are you going to say that?
Thinking about it,
I switched last minute and Kevin with check scare.
You don't want that.
But if somebody wants to think that then fucking fine.
Yeah,
but don't do anything about it.
Fine.
Right.
You don't want them around you.
But that's not up to you.
I don't want fucking about,
but your spreads around me either if you love it to me.
Okay.
All righty.
If you start a factory producing the Irish fear tee shirts and you're in that
office all day long,
you choose to answer the phone cause you want to take care of this business.
Correct.
And you're hired two guys and one of them turns out to be racist and every day
he says a bunch of stupid racist shit and he poisoned by making the environment
that it's different.
Well they all are.
Anybody that's racist or sexist and they say something at home and find out.
They say something later at outside of office hours at home,
then no,
that's not a problem for my office.
Not Outside of.
Okay,
so it's legally to join the Klan.
How dare it's legal to do this very outspokenly racist thing that's legal.
You know the clan is trying to invite Puerto Rican Zinn.
Really?
Why they're invest short,
failing all these other people and showing up,
trying to expand their horizons.
I'm talking Mr. Yes,
they are.
Oh my God.
That's amazing.
I pull up the story.
The KKK is trying to expand their horizons.
It doesn't seem like a good idea,
but inviting minorities.
I just Puerto Rican,
so why bother?
Well,
I think they're trying to solve what does to vilify people that say racist
things is make it so that no one can speak.
The KKK is accepting black members.
Here is what is actually happening.
This is hilarious.
Yeah.
Just come into the clubhouse guys.
I just go through this door was sectional Jewish people.
Yes.
You're ready,
Randy,
to accept African Americans,
man,
you would really have to hate other black people to join the KKK as a black guy.
Click on it instead of just,
yeah.
We're having a bit of an issue here.
Hm.
Well,
in this time,
I guess I should tell you guys to starting a week from Thursday,
my storytellers show this is not happening is on every night after at midnight.
Oh,
good Lord.
That's amazing.
People who do it include from this podcast,
Joe Rogan and made incredible Chrysler's on Diaz is on a bunch of people deal
hugely.
Rob Corddry.
Oh my goodness.
Segura powerful.
Toxocara fuck a bunch of people.
Miss Pat.
I'm forgetting a lot.
But Anyway,
eight weeks.
Oh,
there it is.
There it is.
I think you'll see a full episode right now if you go to the comedy central App
or comedy central standup.
But I gotta tell Ya,
I like the classic jacket you're wearing there.
Something like that.
I got that in Hong Kong and look good.
It looks like I'm very good.
They told me I had to,
uh,
I had to break out one that'll fit the whole time.
And I was like,
you know what?
That was the right time for this suit.
Yeah.
How many shoots you have to now I've got to both made in Hong Kong.
Damn.
I had a third.
But that was like,
move out to la.
Find a real job.
Did you decide like the style,
did you
just help me?
Just the,
I was handmade.
It looks nice.
I mean a,
a style piece.
The wall that they have a style choose from.
There's like a few different cuts you can,
you can choose rocky.
He's the best.
That's amazing.
Dude,
you weren't tailored suits.
That's dope as fuck.
If we had your bucks,
son,
Europe baller,
you're an international baller international look at you should fear and it's
not herpes.
I remember when you were a doorman at the comedy store and now you're an
international mother.
Fucking baller.
A true American success story.
True American.
Holla at your boy.
Alright.
Shall fear next.
Yeah.
You excited to have your special play?
I'm excited.
I gotta be honest,
man.
Uh,
the people who listen to this podcast,
so the reason I was able to do that,
you know,
it was at the comedy central,
would even like come up to a guy like me because of the force behind this thing.
There's no way I can try to be as,
as good as I want,
but if I'm an outsider,
which I was,
that's it.
They didn't come and call on that way.
Yeah.
You know,
there's no outsiders anymore.
Yeah.
This is the real life.
Like these kind of shows,
Internet shows where there's no network behind it.
That's the last bridge.
Yeah.
It was the last bridge between people.
So people find me.
That's great.
And they put the money behind it.
Do a cool special at the comedy store,
make it look all cool.
Yeah,
don't play any of it Jim.
It looks great.
Looks Great.
I like the way that came out.
It looks awesome.
I mean it's so obviously the or,
but yet would like a little twist to it with those lights behind you.
Pretty cool.
Just like ever so slightly.
I took it down so much.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Why this light bulb?
Get it out.
Yeah.
That fucking room is magical.
Great.
That room doesn't leave any,
there's,
there's no space for horse shit and there's no space for more shit.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's weird like a riff and it's like,
good luck.
Well you can't cat.
And that's how it was bad example.
I mean like if it's not all there and you're like,
ah,
that we should have worked like,
no,
he wasn't good.
You've made a bad riff.
It's okay.
They're not going to just laugh anyway.
Well,
it just forces you into that position where you really got to try hard to find
the right words and like that's one of the things that was talking about earlier
about this time that we're in right now.
One of the cool things about it is if there's so many other really funny guys
around that we were all feeding off each other and you get inspired by each
other.
So you like everything is sort of ramped up in your,
even in your mind like,
oh your,
your connections to comedy,
your ideas are sort of ramped up because there's all these really good guys
around you all the time.
You know?
I think that's,
that's huge for any sort of,
oh yeah,
absolutely.
The Bar,
you see the bartender Meyer.
Yeah.
It's once you see the bar set all high,
they're just like,
well that's what I should be aiming for.
Fall short of that,
which you will the beginning anyway.
Then it's like you're falling short at a 50th percentile,
but if the bar is set at 40 yeah,
if you fall barely short,
you're still 39.
Well I think also one of the things that we sort of exhibited,
um,
after,
uh,
after I left the comedy store and when we started doing a lot of shit on the
Internet and start doing this podcast is that we're all sorta like banding
together as like,
like a group.
Like there's a,
a group of comedians that are all banding together and the more everybody else
does good,
the more everybody else does feel like more comedy.
Yeah.
But if people see filter on like I saw my filter on this great man.
You should know about him.
Yeah.
In your town you should go with the guys like that.
It's like,
oh,
everybody's feeding off everybody and it's getting to this like really
interesting like pitch.
And if you look at like great communities,
great communities of musicians,
great communities of comics,
like the,
the old Boston days that everybody always talks about like this.
I think this this day,
right now,
hey,
day is the hay day.
They're like,
we're in the heyday right now.
When I look around era.
Absolutely.
I agree with you without any of us in this room.
When I look,
I just extract us from the equation.
Just look at all the,
if you are just a comedy fan that was an insurance salesman or whatever,
like this is maybe the best time ever.
Yeah.
There's so many guys I want to say right now,
so one of those guys has a special permit,
the 16th at midnight,
1159 and it storytellers show probiotic January 22nd at,
but you should just be extra footage.
I Area Ari shift for the grade,
but some people just don't open up the walls that way.
If you're not a buyer,
then you're no buyer.
Still Watch it.
Yeah,
but you could it just for the Jew and a,
I think it was under his is.
How do you feel about people pirating that Una?
Is that ultra insulting?
No.
What do you mean?
Why would it be insulting if someone said,
hey,
I got this awesome thing.
No,
I'm looking at this thing.
They're pirating your and a do you not understand what I'm saying?
You're going to look back and see how cheap joke.
Oh,
I got it.
Sorry.
My fault.
Well,
you are a non Jewish supporter of pirating.
Like you never give a fuck.
Like you don't have this attitude like trying to maximize your income.
It's like some people get ya.
Yay.
Of course.
The June is only available for the download,
so if you don't get by the download,
how else are you going to see other than somebody fucking doing something with
it,
somebody saying,
hey,
you should come see this.
That's the way people,
you know,
they'll wrestling tapes were like that.
Let me show you.
Oh,
this wrestling match you didn't know about.
That's how you fucking,
that's why I just did a rough thing with wrestling.
Wrestling.
Yeah.
Well he used to trade tapes because it would look the regional ones around like
local TV.
Oh,
so people would have old tapes.
I'm like,
Oh look at,
this guy's moved and they would that.
It wasn't that.
It wasn't pirating.
It was like sharing information.
That's all this shit is.
I put up my own Intelsat for fucking cause Viacom.
I kept taking it down really,
but I had to call comedy central.
I'm like,
can you please put up my Intel set?
And they're like,
yeah,
okay.
Wow.
But it's like Ha,
just kidding.
Let me,
it disbursed my information.
Yeah.
If I think people are under the impression that if something's online,
they won't watch the television as much.
Separate markets,
separate markets.
You don't,
Bo Burnham released a special on Netflix and youtube.
Yeah.
Well he's a youtube celebrity.
I know,
but the people who watch it like that on youtube or not the kind of people want,
it's just like a sort of separate,
there's a little overlap,
but they're sort of separate.
There's an,
I watch concerts online and also overall for ticket sale.
That's great.
Well those are also enough that spend that seven bucks a month every month on
Netflix and it's just as easy to get it through Netflix.
Like you're,
there's so many options of things that you can watch if you watch something like
Netflix.
Yeah.
And so and no commercials,
no commercial,
seven bucks,
no current.
Who has commercials,
right?
It's who half those commercials here and knowing what the same ones.
Yeah.
Like why are you showing the same commercial three times in an episode?
It is pretty fast though.
They're trying to steal your soul.
The cranky extra loud too.
They don't have those rules on them.
Come on,
man.
I mean,
neighbors were building,
listening.
Yeah.
Like if you're watching the walking dead or something like that,
that's really spooky being quiet guy.
Go look at them.
Those are packed.
You know,
it's funny.
All these networks have this very specific,
like,
this is what we want our network to be to be about.
And then I take these fucking ads that is so offensive to anyone sense of
creativity,
Taco bell ads that just fucking garbage based on shitty jokes you've seen a
thousand times and you're like,
this is what you're putting on in between your fucking awesome shows.
Nothing make a fucking better standard for your commercials.
Like what was flowing it's bought is very straight pitch.
You know,
use this bank will get you a better Apr.
Mm or not corny.
It's the time of the intrusive commercial gone intrusive,
isn't she?
Rusike that seems ridiculous.
Now you're getting those awesome entertainment.
That's why nobody plays commercials on podcasts and if you want a model of it
and go a real commercial,
a lot of we still do.
But if you want to watch like a television show at White Castle,
that's why you're a hold of your,
sorry.
If you want to watch a television show on a and e that's also available on
iTunes and you're going to have to watch with commercial.
What are you talking?
It's crazy.
Isn't it crazy?
I haven't watched TV like that and so long.
It just seems like so crazy what that will be in the future.
What we think of is blockbuster video right now.
Like the idea of going to blockbuster and getting a video is so alien right now.
Like unless you're like in Hawaii,
you know you're staying in a room.
It has a DVD player.
When the fuck are you renting DVDs.
You're not never that shit's reluctant.
Redbox,
but that's like Middle America,
those people,
those fucking miners and shit.
It's like older people,
they go to the grocery store,
they can pick these sets of standards too.
Like what are you somebody,
some interviewer asked me like what I think about the standards.
I'm like,
they're not for the people who would like me.
The standards.
You're not going to say these words or something like that.
You know?
I'm like look,
FCC rules.
But like,
and anyone who would become a fan of mine wouldn't care about those rules.
Yeah.
So for me to say fuck,
or for me to say something gross,
it's like none of my fans will care.
Yeah.
The idea that you're going to like gets a housewives,
what are you doing?
That's not me and my family get out.
They won't watch anyway.
There's plenty of dummies out there that don't want to hear your swearing or
that there would be offended by certain subject matter.
There's nothing you going to do about that,
but just don't watch.
But there's so many people.
That's the thing that people are considering that,
that people never considered when they were giving advice to comics back in the
day when they're telling them to be clean.
So many people,
if you get a piece of the Pie Pie's many people,
you can fill up on a piece of the Pie.
That's the big one,
1000000th of a percentage.
The Pi has 300 million possible just to here in this country and look at
Starbucks.
There are companies like,
oh,
this is great.
We expand,
expand and not just in Seattle and then I all over the country.
It's like,
great.
oh,
guess what?
The Pie is fucking 18 times that big.
Yeah,
go to the whole world and they're like,
what?
And then you make so much more money.
Exactly how I should feel and it's all about the money.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
The five or $10 to get my special pen paid regular.
That's out right now@alreadyshipper.com it's five or 10 you can get tend to get
the audio to,
oh you get like a top iTunes on on a on Tuesday.
Oh that's cool.
So you get like a package deal.
Yeah.
You got a fee.
Damn son moving forward and I'm trying to arrange with comedy central too.
So we're trying to get this like algorithm or just based on like,
cause they're like starting new system and they're pretty cool.
They were like all right you've done this online before to us.
Like what do you got?
Any thoughts?
And I was like yeah when someone buys a Joe Rogan special after that said you
might also like,
and then you got to tell,
find some names of guys like Saguaros half hour of my hour.
Like yeah that should come up.
And then if you're like me then after you watch that it's like here's some other
people you might like,
not just random dudes.
Don't put a Bob Saget after me.
People you actually do like,
like have it like this is a similar,
don't say oh,
not answering or like have it,
don't say it three times.
It'll show up.
Uh,
mid Seventies.
Dad,
dad family kicked the door at some fucking yeah.
Just have shit like that.
So they try to build something like that for their website,
for the CC direct stuff.
And it's like,
yeah,
keep building.
Yeah,
that's a good idea.
Good idea.
All due respect to Dat Pham,
I voted for him.
Did you first seek first year he was voted,
you actually called it a photo.
It's,
no,
I was one of the,
I was one of the judges.
I've voted on the show that got him in home opening his phone.
I'm not going to contribute my part of the solution.
That was when him and Ralphie may head to head for one and two,
right?
Oh yeah.
Ralphie may was there.
Who was three that year?
Um,
I don't remember.
Yeah,
I was just in the beginning like when they were trying out beyond the show.
Oh,
right.
That was one of the judges on that.
They'd have comics go up and do sets.
You just,
just try it out for the new season.
Really.
Cause it was the best trial process ever seen.
Wow.
They don't reject you or set you right there.
They just,
you go up,
there's a full crowd at the Improv.
Go Up to three minutes,
get off,
leave.
Who's the host now?
I don't know.
Maybe Wanda Sykes.
Oh,
that's a good move now.
They had her already.
She's built elemis did it for a while,
right?
Yeah,
he was never here.
How dare you.
He was,
I'm a fan.
Bill Bellamy Til I die too.
I thought I forgot.
That was,
that was,
uh,
um,
who was Ingram's black character.
What's English black character?
Darnell.
His favorite topic was the bill Bellamy.
Oh,
you remember that one bit.
We're here like with the Rolodex.
It's called bitches
sir.
Now,
or maybe during that was his cousin.
Darnell was his cousin.
What the fuck?
I can't remember his name.
Oh yeah.
Marijuana.
No character.
His cousin told you.
Hear about Jeremiah.
What happened?
Watkins,
what guide?
Uh,
like a skin cancer.
And he had got a big chunk taken out of his back.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I'm doing this show tonight and I told you three clubs.
Sure,
yeah,
yeah.
He's got a brace on guys.
Why do you have an Arbor?
You answer maybe.
What if we found out that seat and fucked up my ass and shot his demon load
wouldn't make cancer through his skin.
I would make cancer if we found out that he had,
Jeremiah was just tired of being on the periphery.
It's a funny comics,
got a lot of talent and just needs to do a lot of these other guys who've done
this deal with the devil saints.
We're just going to put the tip in the tip.
People session trust,
you know,
seem to do much cause you're very talented already.
I really think have to put the tip.
It's just the tip.
Oh what's that?
It's hard to relax when you're talking to me like that.
That was like,
I got a six mile.
Did you hear the fluttering of his wings?
He shoots his hot load on your back.
Hot Olive oil
as your skin fucking rides in agony.
Whereas load eight through.
That's it.
Folks.
Can I stay in this podcast?
That's Friday,
January 16th on where?
1159 on comedy central.
1159 pbrs right now.
Why even right.
Even risk it will if it's 1159 that means that it's uncensored,
correct?
Yeah.
Yes.
Beautiful,
glorious uncensored on television.
He can say Cunty I said contains bleeps over the cuss words.
That's right.
Oh,
that's good.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Watch that then.
Oh,
that's good.
Oh fuck yeah.
Leaps are annoying.
They do whatever they want.
Yeah,
and then the following week,
January 22nd Thursday and every Thursday after that,
this is not happening.
Premiers the first ones with me,
but I believe Keegan Michael Key crushes on the second one and the intro to the
second one is amazing jump.
Tom's like that guy who did the intros to eight different intros for eight
episodes.
He's out of his mind.
Awesome.
Google lead.
Mooglie,
ladies and gentlemen,
could googly mogul Joe Rogan's on week five or six I think for him.
That was fun,
man.
Yeah.
Awesome.
I love the fact that you're doing in that weird little strip joint place too,
but he chose place.
Weird environment.
That's such a great vibe.
A little unpretentious vibe.
Like I think the vibe of that place like helps those shows because it's not a
comedy club where you demand like a strip club,
relax.
What are you upset about it?
So the base themselves here and you,
you having a lot of people to come on that aren't even comics sheer.
Yeah,
it's great.
it's good.
Great idea man.
So you get full
beautiful.
The see it on comment.
He's sandshrew Ari's balling chuck a Jack and Jack.
We have got this smart,
oh that's right.
Tomorrow.
That too.
Yeah.
January 14th we will all be at the comedy store for Sam [inaudible] Rogan
Naughty show that I think it starts at 9:00 PM is that correct?
Yeah.
Rogue.
Ari Shaffir is going to be,
Morgan Murphy is going to be there.
Uh,
January 30th I'm at the Mirage in lost wages.
It's Ronnie's fighting again after you told them like you may as well get in
there and asked to fight again.
Yeah,
he got right back in three weeks later.
I've never seen twice in a month.
Damn.
It feels good to be a gangster.
God.
Yeah.
I wish it were coming with him.
Yeah,
that would be cool.
I got all this shit.
Ah,
fuck.
Yeah,
I'm good.
I'm going to Boston with the end.
Was that to Joel Lozan fight?
Was he supposed to told what was supposed to five?
I think he get hurt.
I don't know if he was supposed to fight Benson body though,
right?
Yeah.
Yes,
he was supposed to be,
but I believe you've got injured.
Um,
wow.
Yeah.
Well thanks Joe Rogan.
You Ari.
Shaffir you're fucking awesome.
Only reason I come up to the valley,
to the Joe Rogan experience,
but shit on the valley.
I was born here till I die.
All right.
Uh,
that's it.
You awesome people.
Oh,
January 30th Mirage,
Vegas,
Ian Edwards and Tony Hinchcliffe.
Chunka Chunka.
Chunka.
See you guys soon.
Much love big kiss.
Bye Bye.